come to the stratford-on-avon district
council meeting
of the 19th of april
this is a virtual meeting and everyone
is asked to adhere to the etiquette for
virtual meetings
as published on the council's website
members
you have been provided with the
council's etiquette for virtual meetings
in advance of this meeting however
to reiterate the main points please
ensure your device is fully
charged or is charging please mute
microphones when not speaking
please indicate in the chat bar if you
wish to speak
and please only use the chat bar to
indicate your wish
to speak and for not other purposes
with one exception which i will come on
to when invited to address the capsule
please ensure your microphone is
switched on
and switch off immediately after you
have finished please ensure
you have switched off or to silent any
other devices you have that may
interrupt the proceedings
if any member encounters i see problems
causing them to drop out of the virtual
meeting
you should use your best endeavors to
rejoin as quickly as possible
should you be unable to rejoin the
meeting you will be deemed to have left
the meeting at that point
and the meeting will continue numbers
you should call should you experience
any difficulties
rit help desk oh one seven
eight nine two six double zero
two zero or caroline nash democratic
services manager
on oh seven nine seven six four one six
three five three please note that the
meeting is being broadcast
live and that members of the public are
able to view the proceedings
with reference to the voting procedure
for virtual meetings
once a motion has been moved and
seconded if no one wants to speak
there will be an assumption that the
motion is agreed without the need for a
formal vote
unless someone indicates in the chat box
to the contrary
accordingly i will pause for a moment to
allow councillors time to respond
in the chat at those appropriate moments
if members are intending to propose any
amendments
could they please indicate and write
them in the chat as soon as possible
this does not refer to any written
amendments already received and
circulated
before the meeting
since we last met we and a
few well short while ago we had the the
sad death
announced of his royal highness prince
philip the duke of edinburgh
and as this is the first meeting of this
council although
formal mourning has ended yesterday we
will now
observe a one-minute silence during
which
the image of the prince will be on our
screens
and the wording alongside is that which
the council and i
are sent to the book of condolences for
the
follow her majesty thank you
thank you we'll now move on to
the agenda the first item of which is
apologies for absence and i call upon
the head of the paid service
to report any apologies received and to
take a roll call of members
in attendance for this meeting
councillors
by confirming you are present you are
also confirming that you can hear
and see the proceedings mr butland
thank you chairman um apologies have
been received from councillors barker
jefferson and kendall as chairman said
i'll now do the vocal so if when i call
your name if you please repeat your name
and confirm that you can please see and
hear the meeting um
councillor dixon that's the dixon i can
see and here
thank you council fitter councillor i
can see and hear the meeting
the cube counselor adam counsel out i'm
here i can
confirm i can see and hear the meeting
thank you
councillorconk council o'clock here i
confirm i can see and hear
the meeting thank you councillor
bromwich
yes council brothers can confirm he's
here and can see
and hear the meeting thank you
councillor cargill
county cargill here and i can confirm i
can see and hear the meeting
thank you please counselor cleave here i
can see and hear the meeting
good afternoon mr buckland uh councillor
crump here i can hear and see the
proceedings thank you
councillor curtis
councillor curtis yes i can see you in
here proceedings thank you thank you
councillor eden
answer eden here i confirm i can see and
hear proceedings
the future fielding cancer fielding here
i confirm i can hear and see the
proceedings
thank you councillor fleming cancer
flaming i can see in here proceedings
thank you
thank you for council of fiji i can
see and hear proceedings thanks thank
you chancellor foreman
councillor foreman i can confirm i can
hear and see the proceedings
thank you councillor ian frenchly
council here and fragility i confirm i
can see and hear the proceedings
thank you councillor jenny frenchley
councillor jennifer actually i confirm i
could see and hear the proceedings
thank you harris good afternoon everyone
i can confirm i can hear and see the
proceedings thank you
thank you councillor harvey confirmed i
can
see and hear the proceedings thank you
council henches therapy
council and just everything i can
confirm i can see and near the
proceedings
thank you councillor jennings councillor
jennings i can hear and see the
proceedings
uh councilman junit councillor junaid i
can confirm that i can hear and see the
proceedings
thank you councillor kettle
councillor kettle i can confirm i can
see and hear the proceedings
council mills i can hear and see all
proceedings thank you
thank
good afternoon everyone i can see and
hear all the proceedings thank you
thank you pemberton thank you chief
executive of members i confirm that i
can see
and hear all proceedings
here i can see and hear the proceedings
thank you
richards councillor richards i can
confirm i can see and hear proceedings
that's riley captain o'reilly i can see
and hear the proceedings thank you
thank you rock down to nigel rock i can
see and hear the proceedings
thank you wolf councillor kate rolfe i
can see
and hear the proceedings thank you
councillor shenton good afternoon
councillor shenton
i can see and hear the proceedings thank
you very much
thank you and our council of wally
hoggins
councillor wally hoggins i can see in
here all proceedings thank you
thank you thank you
thank you mr butland moving on to item
two the disclosures of interest and i
now invite members and officers to make
their declarations of interest to the
meeting
please indicate in the chat function
your wish to speak and to declare
but before i approach the chat i know
mr grafton would just like to mention
something for the twin hatters
thank you thank you chairman
so this concerns item 15 on your agenda
which is the motion from
council of phoenix in connection with
street lighting
um just for the um sake of
um speaking and voting um
any member of this council who is also a
member of
warwickshire county council and or is
going to take part in the election there
is no need for you to declare an
interest because the only mention
of the county is in relation to
developing
a strategy to assess safety so
there's no need for you to declare any
interest thank you chairman
sorry about that my screen wasn't
allowing me to unmute
that councilor rock has indicated please
uh thank you chairman i wonder if mr
grafton could just uh
uh uh comment on the on item
seven then fix some travel uh
arrangements because that will
presumably affect us all and we uh
we need a blanket dispensation i imagine
mr grafton yes i'm quite happy to grant
a dispensation to everyone
um on the basis that without that
dispensation there wouldn't be a fair um
discussion thank you mr grafton uh
councillor adam you've indicated as well
thank you chairman um i just wanted to
declare
that i am the candidate in the
warwickshire
uh police and crime commissioner
election that's currently ongoing i
believe
that may have some relevance to the
motions of notice but no
specific one uh i thought it just better
to um
to make a declaration in case
thank you councillor adam and council uh
pertiguella you've also indicated
yeah i like to um have advice as well
from phil grafton because item nine
which is the
notice of motion uh tackling food
insecurity and promoting food justice
i will be referring to a buddhist county
council
then i would like to know whether we
need to declare um
that we are standing um or not
mr grafton
um chairman i i can't think at the
moment that there would be a declaration
but it really depends on what um
what counselor peter gallery is going to
be saying can she give some indication
thank you counselor together yes i will
reiterate
uh the you know we need to work together
and um you know ever
a collaborative encouraged approach with
worship county council
um in in that case can't
cancel it pertiguello i don't think
there's any need for you to declare an
interest
thank you mr grafton nobody else
indicating
right okay then uh that takes care of
item two which was the disclosures item
three the minutes
as already announced to avoid the
necessity of a roll call for the minutes
it has been agreed that you indicate in
the chat if you have any objections or
abstentions
if none are received it will be presumed
that you are in agreement with the
accuracy of the minutes
please note that councillor patagella's
question to the leader
was not incorporated within the minutes
which will be
amended to include her question i have
also received
a course a communication from
one of our councillors regarding the
uh minute of item 574
minute 438 on page six of the minutes
members which was the debate we held
on working together with warwick
district council
at the end of the final paragraph
there it reads members were assured that
full consultation would be carried out
ahead of any decisions taken
and that members would be fully informed
of the program as it progressed
i would now like to add upon conclusion
of the debate a vote was taken
with one counsellor counselor wally
hoggins
voting against the recommendation
accordingly
it was resolved one that subject to as
written
in the minutes there that amendment
i believe has the support of mr grafton
and with that one amendment to those
i now ask if there are any other points
which counselors wish to
point my direction in the chat please
counselor harvey thank you chairman
um i don't have a specific point to
raise on the minutes
except to say that i think
congratulations are due to the staff who
have prepared these minutes
it was a lengthy meeting ending up
having to produce a 41-page account of
that meeting
is no trivial matter minutes
the writing of minutes is an
underappreciated art
and i just register that i do appreciate
all the hard work that's gone into
preparing these minutes
thank you very much councillor harvey
wellstead and uh it is uh
taken on board and accepted by those
members of the committee team which are
in my presence at the present time
without any further comments the minutes
will be signed at the end of this
meeting they will indeed be amended to
incorporate
not only those words which i've just
added at the end of minute five three
eight
but also counselor per toguela's
question to the leader
which is not included in the minutes but
was
uh subsequent to the last meeting
received and responded
all to moving on now to
uh we now move on to items for reference
to the council item four which is the
announcements
and i'll start with a couple from myself
with regard to my email message which
was sent to all councillors
in which i advised that although the
period of formal mourning will have
ended
we would hold a one-minute silence in
response to the sad death
of his royal highness prince philip the
duke of edinburgh i fully respect those
councillors who have responded with
their individual opinions
on this subject may i now also advise
members that the
shakespeare birthday celebrations have
unfortunately again this year had
to be uh cancelled as they were last
year because of
the covid restrictions etc however i
would mention two members that
filming did occur last week and will be
broadcast on
friday the 23rd on the appropriate
youtube channel
essentially filming took place at the
town hall at the birthplace trust
at holy trinity uh those are my
announcements because
continuing with clovid it has indeed
remained
a quiet period for the chair
i now invite the deputy leader and the
chief executive to make any
announcements
that they wish to make first of all the
deputy leader
council pemberton uh thank you chair uh
sitting in
uh on behalf of uh the leader um
who members will know is uh he is um
is not able to participate i have no
announcements that have been forwarded
to me by the leader for reporting to
council
i am hopeful and expecting that the
leader will be
back in harness for our annual meeting
and if there are any uh announcements
uh he will catch up on that uh at the
next meeting thank you chair
thank you councillor pemberton uh david
butland please
thank you chairman just the one um just
as members will be aware that
the the regulations that allow for
counseling
decisions to be made um in remote
meetings come to an end formally on the
6th of may
2021 and as you would imagine your your
committee services team
the monitor officer and myself are
working on
contingency plans to reins
reinstate um physical meetings
we are still though waiting the outcome
of the court case which has been bought
by
the association of democratic services
officers lawyers and local government
half of your county council and is now
also supported by
the ministry for housing communities and
local government which is due to be here
heard on the 21st of april
uh just this week should that court case
define
place to include the remote place then
the intention is
that we will continue to with uh remote
meetings
for the foreseeable future if that court
case is unsuccessful
then as mentioned we'll have to put into
place
um contingency amendments to reinstate
physical meetings for
the decision-making committees of the
council such as the kavanaugh
planning committee council um other
committees
such as the adrian scrutiny committee we
intend will continue still
as virtual meetings but just want to
give you that update um chairman we are
waiting that there's not that cool case
just this one
thank you mr buckland i noticed on the
announcements that councillor kettle
would
like to speak uh councillor kettle
um yes in view of the deputy leaders uh
comments about
our leader's absence uh he is going in
for a
um uh surgery in about ten days time and
i just think it'd be appropriate for
this council to wish him well
uh for that operation um
this is the reason he's off games today
that i think is uh thank you thank you
councillor kettle and i
the indeed i'm sure the council all
expresses uh that
tony has a successful uh operation and
is soon back with us
moving on now to item five questions
received from members of the public
we have received one question for this
meeting the details have been published
on the website
together with the response of council of
pemberton the deputy leader
and portfolio holder for place i
understand that mr mike roberts will be
dialing in to ask a supplementary
do we have mr roberts on the line i
gather mr roberts is there are you uh
able to hear me mr roberts
you can't you you may need to press star
six
to connect hello we can hear you mr
roberts do you have a supplementary
question at all having seen
the original question and the response
on the website
uh i do have a supplementary question
but before that i'd just point out that
the
uh councillor has completely ignored the
question once again
the the question i asked the council was
the only policy compliant development at
the site would be limited to
redeveloping existing buildings and
plans directly related to the
enhancement of the established crime
section
and aviation facilities the councillor
has not addressed that
question in his reply i was at the
airfield on sunday
for half an hour i saw one aircraft
movement a completely empty car park
the landowners are completely out within
the council on this and continue to run
down the airport and
by the council of ignoring the question
it's not helping things at all but i
still do have a supplemental question
okay well it should be noted that the
original question hasn't been uh
answered uh during the during the legal
case
um to remove the business tenants at
wells one airfield
of their protected tenancies the owners
at the airfield
claimed they would not uh if they could
not obtain planning permission to
demolish the tenants building they would
not in any circumstances
allow the tenant's premises to be reused
for aviation in the future
however it's since come to light since
the trial that an agreement was already
in place to allow
a former aviation tenant to remove
to go back to the premises that
allegedly were due to be
demolished landlords have effectively
committed perjury allegedly in court in
order to gain control of the airfield
in view of this and subsequently the
landowner is signing an agreement with
sbc
that agree they agreed to enter into
negotiations with all the tenants at the
airfield
an agreement that was not appalled it is
clear that the landowners
cannot be trusted partners to deliver an
airfield at the site
and it should be obvious to the council
that their true intentions
are to redevelop the site given that
there was already a sustainable effort
on the site
one that landowners have chosen to run
down for the past five years
will the council confirm that there
should be no obligation to the council
to offer a non-aviation development at
the site in order to make a sustainable
airfield
and also appreciate an answer to the
original question
roberts i now have
asked councillor pemberton to respond
thank you before i respond in any way
shape or form i think i would like to
take some advice from uh
our legal officer there were a number of
things
in the preamble to that question that i
think i would be uncomfortable
responding to
in relation to allegations about other
parties um
i'm not really sure i can go anywhere
with that i would would welcome some
guidance from the monitoring officer
thank you uh councillor pemberton i'll
in case i'll take a
very short two-minute adjournment to
enable you and the
legal team to exchange views
chairman i'm i'm quite happy to to
advise in public
um councillor pemberton you're right to
the extent that it's not for the
for the district council to make
comments
about um allegations against the parties
so if you wish to confine yourself to
the
supplementary part of the question
that's that's fine thank you
council of pemberton thank you i'm
comfortable with that
please proceed then i am just a
chair just formulating my response
thank you for your supplementary
question uh mr roberts i will answer as
far as
uh i am is possible and with the
guidance of
our monitoring officer um
the position of this council is that it
has a policy position
setting out the aspirations for the
continuance of flying functions
at wellsborne airfield and those are
referenced in my
original answer to you the
council has rightly and properly
entered into a memorandum of
understanding
with the land owner as part and parcel
of
the compulsory purchase order
process on behalf of the council i am
satisfied that that is a right correct
and proper course of action that the
landowners
are the appropriate uh legal owners
and through their representatives
gladmans are the organization with which
any discussion uh should take place uh
that is exactly what we are doing and
i would refer mr roberts to the final
paragraph of my
original answer where it says that
productive negotiations are currently
continuing it is the council's intention
that any long-term use of the site will
see aviation continuing
and will be in compliance with adopted
planning policy
i have nothing further to add to that
chair so
i think now we move on thank you
councillor pemberton thank you
mr roberts
moving now to item six of the agenda
matters for determination by the council
item six is questions by councillors and
i invite council pemberton as deputy
leader
to introduce this report i know mr
grafton is available to assist if
required
thank you chair um and uh i will
undoubtedly be calling on mr grafton
members this is before you because
uh an inconsistency uh between council
procedurals and committee procedure
rules has been identified by councillor
nigel rock
and i thank him for his diligence in
highlighting
what is an anomaly officers have worked
to bring forward recommendations
to close that particular anomaly
and i would be grateful if mr grafton
would be
able to give some background to members
so that they have some
some context for the recommendation that
is set out
on page 43 of your papers
the recommendation is that committee
procedure rule 12.4
be amended to read that the oral
response to questions by counsellors
will be recorded in the minutes of the
meeting mr grafton if you can
help us all please
mr grafton yes certainly thank you
chairman
so um for some unknown reason uh perhaps
last lost in the annals of
the history of the constitution
there is at the moment a discrepancy
between
the committee procedure rule that deals
with this issue
and the council procedure rules and the
difference is that
if you ask a question orally at
a committee meeting um the answer that
you're given
is not as yet required to be recorded in
the minutes
of the meeting whereas if you compare
that with the equivalent minute um
council rule in the council procedure
rules
it is so it's quite a straightforward
point
the proposal therefore is as councillor
um has explained
is to bring the two rules into alignment
by making sure that any oral question
asked at the committee meeting will be
recorded in the
subsequent minutes of that meeting thank
you
thank you mr grafton
have we any comments in respect of item
six obviously the proposal
is uh from councillor pemberton the
recommendation
you're proposing
ah councillor rock thank you uh thank
you chairman
uh i'm not i'm not sure if the if the
recommendation's
already been proposed if it hasn't i
will if it has been i'll second it
and and i think as a
has been adequately explained this
brings it all into line
i trust that this will enable us to
deal with questions at the appropriate
level at council committees
um then it might otherwise have been
brought to council to deal with quite
detailed procedural matters um so i
would recommend it to council and on our
i hope we can do
the matter speedily thank you chairman
thank you councillor rock councillor
check
thank you chair it was just a question
for um
phil grafton um if
if these two procedures are not in line
with each other
um so you have a slightly different set
of rules for full council meetings
um does is is that legally
questionable um because i'm just a
little bit uncomfortable with the fact
that now once these new rules are in
place
if they are voted in today that there's
no way of asking the leader a question
at a full council meeting is that
correct
so i'm not sure what the connection is
between asking a question to the leader
because that
that issue is already dealt with fully
in the council procedure rules and
that's the only place that you would be
asking such a such a question to the
leader
unless unless of course the leader
happened to be um
at a council meeting in some of the
capacity
just coming back to your first part i i
don't see any reason why
there might might not be some difference
between
the rules we have for running council
meetings
and the rules we have for running other
committee meetings it does
it doesn't equate to some kind of
unlawfulness there might be very good
reason for it but in this particular
case
i agree with councillor rock that there
isn't any good reason why the two rules
are different
thank you mr grafton gaston happy with
uh that response yes sir thank you
thank you thanks for clearing that up
thank you
uh i will now ask uh
councillor pemberton to formally propose
and i think uh councillor rock
to second uh the recommendation on item
six councilor pemberton
thank you chair i formally bring forward
the recommendation that committee
procedure rule 12.4 be amended to read
that the oral response to questions by
counsellors
will be re recorded in the minutes of
the meeting i propose that and uh
i i understand councillor rock will
second that thank you
council rock
secondary chairman thank you very much
indeed
i should now pause as indicated nobody
else is indicating
a request to speak so there'll be no
votes on that matter
and the item is concluded and agreed
thank you moving through now
to item seven the fixed some travel
payment
and i invite councillor pemberton as
deputy leader of the council to
introduce this
report uh phil is again available to
assist if required
councilor pemberton thank you chairman
and once again i shall be calling on mr
grafton to provide some background
context for members
uh for this item members will recall
that
following on from the pandemic we took
a decision to suspend the payments of
the fixed sum travel payments provided
by
in the counsellors scheduler of
allowances
in light of the government's indication
that it wishes to move back
to a pre-pandemic
arrangement for meetings uh whereby
meetings are uh principally face to face
uh certainly all decision-making
meetings are face-to-face um
we now must give some consideration as
to whether to fix
some travel payment should be reinstated
from the 7th of may
whether it should be
held in abeyance should the the legal
action allow for virtual meetings
um uh and uh
therefore should there be some extension
to that um
so at that point i think i'll ask mr
grafton to
uh just to come in with some some
background context because this is not
all so this is not only about attending
uh physical council committee meetings
thank you councillor pemberton mr
grafton
uh thank you chair um paragraph 1.4
the report does explain
that the allowance also covers for
travel
within the district councillors ward for
example for
site visits but
at the the options which is on paragraph
2.2 2.3 2.4
um the focus of the options for your
decision
do tend to concentrate on whether
virtual meetings are going to continue
or not
which is slightly missing part of the
point
and the reason for that is when you go
back to the reason that we first
introduced
travel allowances back in october 2019
the independent remuneration panel
report on which you relied
spoke of a number of reasons why the
allowance might be introduced
so just going through those it said
that there might be the need for a
personal visit regarding a particular
planning application
it might be that the member decided to
come into elizabeth has to see an
officer
it might be the member is visiting
constituents and local community
groups and those were other reasons
there for
why originally you introduced
the allowance so when you're considering
options one two and three and which one
to choose i would just ask you to bear
in mind
those are the factors as well thank you
thank you mr grafton councillor bromwich
you've indicated to speak
yeah obviously i was the person who
proposed the suspension of this um
fixed travel payment some when we
decided to suspend it
and my present position is actually i
don't think we should be reinstating
this at the moment
of this i don't believe we are going to
any of us are going to be substantially
putting any hardship
in any any time soon my personal
preference is that i think we should
suspend this
and review it with a view of whether we
re-implement it next year
or not about this we do get paid march
allowance on top of this where
things such as going to meetings whilst
i know
that certainly council field is going to
turn around and say he's got a lot of
parishes to cover and a lot of distance
to cover
at the moment that we don't know whether
we're going to be allowed on virtual and
as i said i still don't think for the
march involved we are
substantially as counselors putting
substantial hardship
off it so my proposal would be to
defer to once more defer this yet again
of this because i do not think it's very
necessary and it sets a very bad example
in the end
versus councillors who at the last
meeting voted through a three and a half
percent
increase on the council tax i think
we're just going to make ourselves look
very stupid in the current climate by
bringing back
this payment thank you councillor
bromwich councillor field
thank you chair um i've had to
make several trips around the ward um
with regards to planning applications
where i have to
present the um to visit the site
particularly when the application has
been refused and it's going to committee
so plus the fact that i also
do drive around my ward to check on
potholes
and other matters which are referred to
by
parish councillors it's not just that i
sit here and accept it i do
do go out the other thing that slightly
puzzled me was this
business of if i if one goes in to see a
planning officer
um that is part of the travel alliance
and anyway it's very difficult to find a
at the moment
a planning officer in the district
council um
but i maintained for working within the
ward it is important
uh particularly the distances we have to
travel i've got a 35
round tripper of my ward and i would
like to see it
brought back
thank you councillor fielding uh
counselor rock
uh thank you chairman um well uh as
uh council bombardment points out uh
i i know this i don't think are gonna
suffer tremendous hardship here
however i strongly feel that anybody of
any means
ought to be able to be a councillor and
i do think
also that councillors should be on a
level playing field
now i've got a high regard
for um tony bromwich
and particularly the work he's been
doing on hs2 however it's very generous
of him to cut the uh
suggest cutting the allowances for
councillors with very large boards
he's got a very compact ward um
as far as my reduction in travel for the
first three months it did
but every time i would look at a plan
application it's very large travel
distances for instance is 20 mile round
trip to my
across my wall to some of the some of
the sites
either to go and see residents or to
look at flooding which i
i regret to say i've been to see
flooding many many times in my ward if
any compton
so i think there's been some
misunderstanding of the principal focus
of these fixed allowances these are not
not to attend meetings whether they're
held virtually or not
these are to go and to be able to
see what's going in one's ward and does
one wants duty
with with great conscience uh now
in the end it's a matter of principle
that i think we ought to
go with this because it was the
recommendation as it has
as phil grafton has told us from the
remuneration committee
so it's not self-interest i think if if
necessary i personally give it up
but i think as a matter of principle we
ought to stick with what's done there so
individual counsellors are not
disadvantaged compared with one's
in compact wards it is to do with having
very large wards
and that was why it was put there in the
first place and i think there's been
a sort of bit of misunderstanding what
it was there for in the first place
thank you thank you councillor rock
councillor harvey
thank you chairman um i think this item
is premature
the key factor that we don't have an
answer to
is the uh the legal interpretation
of uh the word um meeting
and the whether we can meet face to face
or not
as uh councillor bromwich quite rightly
points out
this allowance was
suspended because of the pandemic and
the
implications of lockdown it strikes me
that
when the restrictions of lockdown
have been lifted and counselors are able
to operate as they normally
would do that's the point of time
when we should consider what we should
do about the reinstatement or otherwise
of this allowance we currently to my
mind
lack that key piece of information of
the interpretation
of whether we can continue to hold
virtual meetings or not
my my preferred solution to this matter
would simply be
not options one two or three but option
four which is to defer it
until we get to the first meeting after
june
thank you chairman thank you councillor
harvey
councillor harris
thank you chair i've not really anything
to add i think the points have been
covered
i do think people should consider that
some of us have a lot further area to
cover
in mileage and time-wise that eats into
it
it is about a preferred playing field
for the councillors who might
out-of-pocket to join the council
and regardless whether it's a word we
should use or not entitlements
it's an allowance we can have and we're
not really paid and a lot of us do a lot
of hours
thank you councillor harris councillor
pemberton
thank you chair um listening to the the
debate
um i'm minded to um what i thought was a
uh a proposal from
councillor harvey uh if that is a
proposal for
an option that is a variation on option
two which allows for deferments
to reconsider the matter at the first
full cancel following on from the easing
of restrictions at the end of june
uh if councilor harvey is making that
recommendation as an amendment i would
support that
thank you councillor pemberton uh
council of fielding has indicated but
i'm afraid council's the fielding you've
already spoken once on this particular
item so it's unless it's a point of
note of a point of order
then i'm afraid council of fielding uh
is nothing i'm
going to invite you to add no anyway
it's just
basically going back onto why it was
brought on by
david dalby who was very keen because we
were meant to have
very counsel you really do not have a
second bite of the cherry
thank you uh councillor riley
um yes i just want to say that um uh
like counselor field he said uh if um
cancer harvey wants to propose that as
an amendment i would support it and be
willing to second it
thank you councillor riley in that case
as uh
we are close to i think to a conclusion
uh from what i can see going on in the
chat i will
ask councillor harvey if he would know
like to make that a formal proposal
um yes mr german i formally propose that
this item be deferred
uh until the first meeting after
lockdown restrictions have been
lifted on the understanding that it is
an option for the council
to back date the the date of any
introduction reintroduction
if that's what the council were to
decide on that basis i propose
thank you councillor harvey and i see
that uh councillor richards is indicated
in the chat council richards
thank you chairman uh just looking to
second that that's all
uh thank you councillor richards
uh for clarification sorry for this uh
silence uh a little debate going on here
so who may have seconded it i waited
until it been formally proposed before
accepting a second
and therefore i'm not going back on what
may have been indicated in the chat or
five previous comments
indicating that if councilor harvey
proposed other people would
second i simply waited for it to be
proposed and then councillor richards
came in very promptly
so the item has been proposed and
seconded
if anybody is against that proposal
nobody indicating in the chat therefore
that
proposal and segment has been agreed and
the murder will come back to the first
meeting
after the end of lockdown ie in july
thank you members
we now move on to determine the
following items referred to the council
from
other committees the first being from
the cabinet held on the 8th of march
2021 agenda item 8
minute 620 the earlswood public space
protection order before i invite
councillor kettle i would like to take
this opportunity to thank
karen stanley sam slomenczek and
jenny logan for this excellent piece of
work
the residents of earlswood in my award
are looking forward to the
implementation
members are asked to note that the map
which was the subject of the public
participation
is the one to be enacted should council
agree
the recommendation now invite councillor
kettle to present the report
and understand that sam is available to
assist as
required counselor kettle
thank you mr chairman um yes this is
a um a really key bit of
uh the work of the the um community
safety team
um it's taken an awful lot of time to
put together i'm not gonna repeat
uh although i i support all the thanks
i've been put forward
by the chairman who is of course award
member um but i would just like to
introduce
um i'm assuming he is here is sam here
in the meeting um the officer prepared
the report
just to summarize the more detailed bits
and pieces he's in a far better position
to say so
which i did discuss with the chairman
beforehand
um so i'm just trying to see if uh sam
samantha is is here
if he is good afternoon encounters the
kettle i am here
um well with the chairman's approval
would you like just to run through the
more technical aspects which you're far
better qualified to talk about than i am
good afternoon sam you have the
microphone
thank you chairman much appreciated uh
good afternoon to all
councillors and officers present
my name's sam slomensek and i work as a
community safety project officer
within the community safety team so
really my primary work at stratford on
avon district council
is around the coordination of
multi-agency approaches and strategies
to crime which includes things like
acquisitive crime violence and
serious and organized crime and that's
very much
my background really so i'm essentially
responsible for that
i'm also essentially responsible for the
public space cctv scheme upgrade
happening in stratford so
in terms of this particular agenda item
i've been specifically involved in
working with
partner agencies on developing
multi-agency responses to the
anti-social behavior
and crime happening within earlswood and
one particular strand of our response is
the proposed public space protection
order
or pspo as i might refer to it
so essentially the the papers compiled
for the earlsword pspo report
summarize the proposal and the steps
taken to bring this about
i'll just take the opportunity to
perhaps reinforce that over the course
of the past five years
there have been increasing reports of
varying types of antisocial behavior
occurring within earlsword
many of these reports focus around four
key areas
which is antisocial behavior occurring
in large groups
alcohol misuse by these groups the use
of drugs and psychoactive substances
namely nitrous oxide in particular and
antisocial behavior relating to vehicle
misuse
the specific numbers of those sorts of
incidents can be found
within the report and within the cabinet
minute meetings so in terms of the
pspos they're a tool that essentially
allow
councils to prohibit specified
activities
and or to require certain things to be
done by people engaged in particular
activities within a defined area
this draft order has been produced
comprises of around four conditions
which
include no psychoactive substances
possession and consumption
no car cruising no loitering and causing
intimidation harassment alarm and
distress
and alcohol consumption where
essentially a person if they fail to
cease drinking alcohol or to surrender
alcohol
when directed by a constable or another
person
and subsequently if you breach those
conditions in the order you're liable to
be given a fixed penalty notice or to be
prosecuted
so this proposal has been developed from
a grassroots community level
a lot of local conversations have taken
place to establish
uh the evidence and necessity for such
an order uh we've worked with
partners including warwickshire police
workshop county council
the police and crime commissioner's
office as well as many local partners
such as tamworth in arden parish council
the canal
river trust the residents association
and local councillors and local
community groups
so really to summarize there's a
significant level of public support for
this order around 98
support in the consultation and wide
scale multi-agency support as well which
is detailed in the report
um there's a number of clear benefits
from this pspo
which includes the deterrent effect of
having such an order in place
uh clear rule setting around that the
additional powers given to the police to
deal with antisocial behavior
and the ability to use those fixed
penalty notices
like i said earlier this is part of a
multi-agency approach to tackling asb
in the area and is part of a package of
other measures that
the district council are taking in the
area
the order's been developed within the
parameters of the anti-social behavior
crime of policing act 2014 and other
relevant legislation
as well as with home office guidance and
local government association guidance
and best practice
so really ultimately that concludes my
additional comments
regarding the pspo proposal and
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to share those
chairmen and if if it's appropriate i
can always answer any questions
or counselor kettle can answer any
questions if appropriate
thank you thank you thank you sam
uh just one question from myself i think
apart from possibly
pspos referring to dog fouling
and the like is this the first one that
this council has put through
in respect of anti-social behavior
alcoholism and the like
yes that's correct chairman the the
powers around public space protection
orders
have only been available since 2014 and
as you suggest
um actually the only uh powers that have
been used have been in relation to dog
fouling that the council's taken so this
is this is the first that looks at
tackling anti-social behavior
it's been a good uh learning curve
without a shadow of a doubt and as i say
thank you very much indeed sam
and now pass back to councillor kettle
thank you mr chairman um uh i hope
i hope uh the silence means rodney uh
questions because
um sam is is by far better based uh
chancellor than me but i think this is a
new step forward for stratford
uh introducing a pspo for this type of
activity
uh as council dixon's members of his
ward have identified
there is a major problem in ellswood um
and uh i think this will hopefully give
them um
some satisfaction that that sort of
criminal activity
and threatening behavior that's been
going on will come to an end
uh so i recommend this proposal to you
and would be very grateful uh if i if i
propose it if somebody would second it
um and um thank you mr sherman
thank you very much councillor kessel uh
as a ward member i'll
i'll desist from seconding it myself uh
i see here councillor shenton has
indicated
councillor shenton thank you chairman
i'm i think this is a
the lakes have been the attraction for
many unfortunately this is uh one of the
attractions that we don't want
and what i'm pleased to see is that the
the various partners in this
have worked together to resolve this
problem and
i have no hesitation in supporting this
100 percent
and quite happy uh just a second list
thank you very much thank you councillor
shenton
nobody is indicated in the chat so
without any voices again
i will to accept that recommendation
and that proposal has been agreed by
council
thank you very much indeed members as i
say the
residents of earls would will be
delighted with that
we now move on to item nine minutes six
two one
notice of motion tackling food
insecurity
and promoting food justice and i
understand from
councillor pettige that she would like
the wording
of the original notice of motion being
on the screens
uh so hopefully that will be facilitated
yes there we have it
uh thank you very much and now invite
counsellor
uh not sorry not supposed together uh
councillor
where am i pemberton sorry as deputy
leader
in the absence of council of barca to
present
actually actually chairman councillor
parry is lined up
to uh respond on councillor barca's
behalf of she's uh
she's not able to make this meeting
thank you thank you very much
councillor parry thank you chairman and
thank you deputy leader
now obviously this notice of motion uh
tackling food insecurity and promoting
food justice was brought forward uh by
councillors pertiguella and eden in
respect of tackling
food insecurity and promoting the food
justice
which was presented at our council
meeting on the 22nd of february
so on behalf of councillor barker who is
the people portfolio
i just i'm here and i wish to advise
that this was given
due consideration in fact considerable
consideration at cabinet
when we were extensively informed and
also advised
that food poverty was already being
reviewed
as part of the warwickshire county
council function
covering adult and child social care
and the the crux of this was that any
work
undertaken by this council would cut
across
partner work already underway
it was also very much recognized
that there was a greater knowledge and
experience of this issue elsewhere
because it's very much comes under the
county council umbrella
and it was therefore considered
unnecessary
for this council to tackle food poverty
as programs were already in place
so the options to cabinet um that were
considered
was either to consider the content of
the motion
at the meeting without the benefit of a
report
from the officers on the implication to
council
of accepting or rejecting the motion or
to defer the consideration of the motion
to await
a report from officers at the next
available meeting the cabinet
or in fact refer the motion to overview
and scrutiny committee for consideration
and report back to the cabinet um
you know that that was that has been
really
key to it all that it made far more
sense
for it to be for for the overview and
scrutiny to consider
the the report and have discussions with
warwickshire county council who already
already doing this work it is also
highly
recognized the bandwidth of our officers
and to reinvent the wheel
on a large piece of work extensive piece
of work
that has already been undertaken it
seemed sensible
and therefore it was recommended to you
know
it was recommended that the over new and
scrutiny
review the warwickshire county council
report
on food poverty and that we invite
county council officers to a future
meeting
in order to discuss that further and
that seemed to be
the most appropriate and sensible
way forward and therefore the motion is
rejected
thank you councillor parry uh i now uh
invite
a second to that recommendation
yeah i i wish to speak um i've seen that
um council of pemberton has secured it
the motion to reject
uh uh the this motion
um yeah can i can i speak or do you want
the remember
uh council of pemberton to speak first
as i've invited yourself i shall
allow you to please proceed at manuela
thank you chair
so i'm very disappointed about this
recommendation for rejection
in particular as one of the other
options available to the cabinet was to
recommend
the motion to the overview and scrutiny
committee
we have several food banks in the
district which feed an increasing number
of our residents
including many of our children who
struggle to get enough to eat or only
have access to unhealthy food
and the kobe 19 pandemic has contributed
to household food insecurity
or poverty which is the lack of
accessibility
to an affordability of nutritional
healthy food
in our local area the trusted trust
network food banks
which includes trafford upon avon foss
and arden food banks
so a rise of 59 percent in demand from
january to december
2020 compared to the same period in
2019-20 there are other local food banks
like the shipstone food bank
and food share initiatives which were
formed during the first lockdown
including in my world an initiative
coordinated by the marston sikka
and quinton parish councils so the
actual number of residents
that cannot afford or access healthy or
nutritional food
could be even higher we need to also
understand
that food banks are the last resort when
residents reach the food bank
they would have already skipped meals
that's why i'm disappointed and frankly
saddened
by the recommendation of the cabinet to
reject this motion
on the basis the warrior country council
is already doing work on this
or that we do not want to duplicate work
or as a cabinet member mentioned
we need to think about officers
bandwidth but the motion
did not ask to do to duplicate any
work it asked for a coordinated
collaborative approach
indeed as warrior county council is
already gathering data
on family poverty and they have just set
up a food forum
and other stakeholders also have a body
of evidence
such as local food banks this data can
easily
be accessed by our council what we are
asking in fact
is a multi-agency approach
where stratfor district council can be
even more effective
and proactively work towards improving
the health and well-being
of our residents including our children
and young people
the motion asks for the council to
encourage potential sites for food
growing
by supporting allowments and community
orchard provisions and helping with
finding and accessing space for
community food growing
and advising on leases and agreements
there are
of course already community initiatives
of growing but often
village allowments are on private land
and therefore eventually the lease could
run out
indeed some allowments were even
included in previous versions of the
site allocation plan
as housing reserve sites or the transfer
of green spaces by developers
to parish councils as you might already
know can be a painful
and expensive process most importantly
the motion asked
to set up a local food poverty action
plan which is something that should be
done in partnership with other tiers of
government
including parish and town councils and
other stakeholders such as food banks
and our local food producers
this this same council voted to explore
the merger to create
a super district a precursor to a
possible south warwickshire unitary
surely such strategic and political
ambition comes with responsibility and
leadership
we should lead on a local food poverty
plan in the areas which
this district council has authority and
our responsibilities also to those
families who need help right now
for the most vulnerable in our towns our
villages our hamlets
and we can do this effectively by
embedding a food poverty action plan
in the council policy decisions there is
already expertise out there
and for example sustain as produce a
guide for local authorities to develop
food poverty action plans
in those areas for which they have
responsibility
so in our case we can use the planning
and business rates relief systems to
shape local areas
for example to support and encourage
community food growing
the creation of food cooperatives as
well as limited the spread of an healthy
fast food outlets we could provide safe
truly affordable housing opportunities
for individuals and households
who may be vulnerable to food insecurity
we can use section 106
or seal funding to pay for initiatives
that are called food insecurity
and the council will not do this alone
it's a partnership
it's a multi-agency approach it has to
be community-wide
it won't be expensive but the benefit to
the earth and well-being of our
residents will be
empowering and positively life-changing
finally the motion asks for the council
to write to our mps
with the evidence in seconds manuela
yeah collected by
our food banks so this surely this is
something that can be easily done and
that we can all agree on
i trust all members here today so this
council to make things better
for the residents and i urge you to vote
against the cabinet's ill-taught
recommendation
to reject this important motion and
instead support
the original motion thank you very much
and i like
a recorded vote please thank you
councillor put together
uh caster pemberton you have indicated
that you would second the proposal
would you like to speak now or would you
like as other members have indicated a
desire to speak
to reserve your position and come in at
the end at council pemberton
i'll reserve my position to the end
thank you chair
against the pemberton in that case uh
councillor
jennings who indicated also a desire to
second council depend but didn't did
beat you to it so
essentially i'll first invite councillor
jennings to add to
uh any comments that he'd like to make
thank you councillor jennings
thank you chairman i have nothing
further to add to councillor paris uh
initial statement thank you very much
thank you councillor jennings uh council
of bromwich you've indicated
yes certainly whilst we all have to
recognize
about food poverty and food and justice
i think um
a bit of personal experience here
probably will be
a little bit of guidance for counsellors
as most counselors know
that three and a half years ago i had to
foster my little cousin because his
mother was able to cope
that's made me have a child who was
deemed a child of need and a child at
risk
and because of that i can honestly say
the support given to me by watching
county council has been absolutely
fantastic
and throughout the cove pandemic in
periods where i have not been
working where my sole income has been uc
and council allowance
that they have given a fantastic support
and so
has southern college on that and they
have
made sure that certainly not just a
child in need
i'm looking after has been well looked
after but others within the area of
seldom
i personally had to go around because
there are people on my ward who are in
areas of poverty and it's widely
recognized on the statistics the lowest
five points five percent in the country
and we've had to deal with things like
food issues now
from a bit of experience on that a lot
of this is also down to education
as well as getting the food actually
into the household
whilst i take on board things like
allotments which i believe
there is a legal obligation if
allotments are
built on that we have they have to be
replaced things like all fantastic ideas
we promoted those in communities
around southern for a number of years do
i think um
this motion is the way forward
i see good value points in it but i
think we need to be
looking at a bigger picture which is
what can we do
as a district council what the county
council
is not doing and i probably agree we've
got a lot of overarching
stuff here i think my good instinct
is we probably need as a council to have
a proper debate
about what we think we can do in
addition to what the county council is
doing
not overarching and i can understand why
the cabinets are making their
recommended
recommendations because there will be a
lot of doubling up
and maybe what we really need is to
actually probably look to set up a task
force properly
rather than go through with this motion
and see what ideas we can come up with
as a collective to put forward to a
council
on how we go forward to continue to
ensure the poorest most vulnerable and
this doesn't just involve children
it involves adults involves old people
involved for
all generations now it's probably
something we've never really talked
about as a council
enough but where there is no re there is
nothing to stop us from saying
whilst this motion may not go forward
that we should be looking
sometime in the next few months to look
at task force
to see what we can actually do and make
recommendations then
to the overviews and scrutinies
committee or the cabinet or full council
or all three i think that is a far more
sensible way forward
than doubling up on what's being done by
another body
i think we need to put this and start
thinking about it in a proper context
and not doubling up on work for
everybody doing the same thing
what we need to be doing is actually
looking forward
saying we have a county council policy
now let's see what additions can we do
as a district council
i don't know what other council's
thoughts are but i think we need to
probably put
a common sense into this
you councilor bromwich uh councillor
o'donnell you are next to indicate
thank you chair um so really i didn't
think i'd say this but councillor
bromwich you've stolen my thunder
on what i was about to say um councillor
pertigalli you will know that at the
cabinet meeting i was fully supportive
of the motion and actually there was
some really detailed discussion about
the fact that we would be doubling up
on work the washington county council
has already undertaken that we wanted to
prevent that at all costs because we
want to make sure that
um when we're looking at such an
important
such an important subject that we
don't leave any stone unturned and that
we make sure we have a holistic
overarching approach so doubling up
would take resources that we could be
putting into making sure that everything
is looked at and considered and that is
why it's really important it comes back
to overview scrutiny
under the guise of the warranty county
council report with their officers
coming into the meeting and with sight
of your
um your motion counselor per together so
we can see where are the gaps and how
does that marry
up with the ideas you've come forward
with because i think you've also started
a really interesting debate
around this subject which needs to be
had and we need to look at it in detail
so i'm very pleased it's coming towards
you and scrutiny we'll be looking at the
work that's already been undertaken
and therefore the resources that would
be on hand to us we can look at what
else needs to be done
so that's just to reassure you that it
is coming back to ovue and scrutiny
um but under the guise of the
warwickshire county council reports
thank you councillor o'donnell
councillor alcock
thank you mr chairman um yet regarding
that yes i understand that while she
county council are putting in a
a work into this and of course doubling
up
um doesn't make sense what does make
sense
is having a district council having a
say
in what you can still county council are
doing
and i think that is actually quite
important
um what we need to do is
we need to make sure that everybody in
the district is looked after
without delay because currently that
isn't happening
it's why we have people using food banks
while we have children who are going to
school hungry
um that that's happening in every single
one of our awards
and that is something that needs
actioning sooner rather than later
um so i don't think that would be over
that i i think that actually this
district can't
be taking it on board um i don't think
the motion should be
rejected outright um i think that sends
an
awful awful message to our residents
um that would that that concerns me
greatly that the district council
decides to
actually know that's it no
so i would like to see it coming back to
overview and scrutiny
and looking at the ways forward
including as councillor bombay said a
task and finish group
a force that can be worked with in our
district
for our residents um
and so yes that is what i would like to
see happening is it going to
overview and scrutiny to work out these
details
thank you thank you councillor alcock
uh before inviting councillor pemberton
uh as nobody else has indicated a wish
to speak
i am aware that uh councillor peter
geller
wished for a recorded vote so i'll ask
if anybody is going to second that
proposal before inviting councillor
pemberton to
possibly wrap up this uh debate uh is
anybody uh indicating to speak
and propose support council uh pangala
pertiguella's request
i'll invite councillor rolf uh to
comment and then i'll go back to
councillor bromwich
one so councillor ralph please
uh sorry i'm slightly confused i was um
are you seconding the arrangement that
it goes to over the years scrutiny
sorry i'm
thank you councillor ralph that is now
seconded uh council of bromwich
you've indicated that you proposing an
amendment
uh can you type that amendment into the
chat please so that we can all see it
i'll try and type it as i'm sort of
thinking it out there so
the prop the amendment proposal would be
that whilst we recognize that the
cabinets have rejected this motion
that instead that instead
the promotion will be sent to overviews
and scrutinies
as in as outlined by the chair of
overuse and scrutinies for the
examination of the walter county council
proposals
and also with a view of setting up a
task and finishing
group to tackle this issue
if that makes sense mega council of
rummage
um for what it may be worth the chairman
is now going to make a comment and that
is
obviously the recommendation before
council
is that the overview and scrutiny
committee review the warwickshire county
council report on food property
and invite the county council officers
to a future meeting in order to discuss
further
i would have anticipated that the
overview and scrutiny committee
having received that report from the
county council
if they then decide themselves that they
wish to set up a task and finish group
to investigate it further i would have
thought that option was fully open to
overview and scrutiny committee
and it could then take place after we
have all seen and been able to
assimilate
the review by the county council but
as councillor pemberton has been already
indicated that i would take him last i
will just see
uh what counselor junaid possibly thank
you
susan to add to this debate uh
councillor junior
uh as the um the
deputy the vice chairman of avogan
scrutiny i would like to
uh also put it more formally what the
chairman of the ovun scrutiny said
that the overview and scrutiny committee
should consider this on their agenda
and review the county council but also
suggest what the district council is
able to do
itself
thank you councillor juliet i think that
sums it up but
very well indeed so we have had
a proposal for a named uh vote we've had
that seconded i now
invite councillor pemberton as
uh someone who was going to second the
initial recommendation
to uh wrap up this debate counselor
pemberton
thank thank you chair um i think the
first observation i would make is that a
number of members have
talked about a debate
i'm not quite sure there is a debate to
be had i cannot
for the life of me think that there
would be any member of this council
who thinks that the increasing
requirement and need and use of food
banks
is anything other than a stain on the
character of a nation that by whatever
measure you
uh take is somewhere between the fifth
and seventh largest economy on the
planet
um absolutely so in the terms of is
there a debate about
should food poverty and food insecurity
exist or not it's not a debate it should
just not absolutely exist in any way
shape or form in this country
um i think just to give some clarity and
some confidence to members
for the avoidance of dads the absolute
intention
is that the overview and scrutiny
committee
do take this matter
on board that was absolutely the will
of cabinet and so if any member is
of the understanding that the this the
the the rejection of the note of the
motion in its in
in its form and and requests for action
at this point
was being completely kicked into touch
is incorrect
and it was the key things to
uh perhaps pick up is uh just again to
give some comfort to counsellor alcock
office of this of officers of this
council
have and continue to work with other
agencies
including the county council and other
partners
on the issue of food poverty and food
insecurity and specifically are working
with colleagues at
warwickshire county council in the
development of their plan
officers are doing work of their own on
this matter
equally members of cabinet were advised
that
the county council are proposing to
bring forward their
report as we understand it uh in july
of this year and therefore we are at a
point as
as we understood it that um we are very
close to the county being in a position
to
outline an overarching strategy that we
can all as districts
and boroughs across warwickshire sign up
to
and also add where it is appropriate for
us to add
to the effort so i think that um
the with the motion itself um
the the notion is that no um there was a
rationale for not
engaging embarking sorry on a piece of
work
at this point when it when as we
understand
the county council's piece of work is so
close
and it is right and proper that the
overview and scrutiny committee should
look at the council county council's
piece of work
and that then can help informing
discussion with officers
uh where this district council can
add to the effort uh that we all share
to ensure that uh um food poverty is
as far as is practicably possible uh
eliminated
so uh on on that basis uh that is
uh uh why i will be uh seconding
councillor
parry in in in relation to this motion
uh but with the absolute guarantee that
it is our our wish
that the other viewing scrutiny
committee do consider the matter further
and i think
the chief executive has indicated he
wishes to uh clarify something
thank you very much council of pemberton
yes i was going to say there has been a
debate going on
in here whilst i've been trying to to
listen to yourself etc
so i'm going to invite mr buckland to
to speak uh because obviously there was
uh
an amendment proposed by councillor
bromick
i missed the indication in the chat from
councillor curtis because
it was just quite simply scrolling
through that quickly i missed it totally
but mr butland if you'd like to uh seek
some clarification please
yes thank you chairman my understanding
is the same as yours to be uh
chairman in that there is two
recommendations coming forward from the
cabinet
to to council the first is that this
matter is referred to the adrian's
grouping committee and that
the evidence scrutiny committee reviewed
the warwickshire county council report
on food poverty
and invite county council officers to a
future meeting in order to discuss
further
the the one element missing from that
recommendation that was proposed by uh
council
um fromage was that and the
task of finnish group be established
that from my take
that's the only thing that is missing
that the second recommendation
is that the notice of motion has printed
be rejected but there was that
recommendation from the cabinet that the
overview and scrutiny committee should
consider this matter if i'm done just
generally if
there was an amendment to the first part
of that recommendation
to specifically say and if um and the
tasking first group be
um adopted then i
or established i think that would that
would um deal with
the issue
thank you mr butland uh mr bromwich
councillor bromwich bugbarden
uh do you wish to include in your
amendment
that a task and finish be a
be instigated when that report comes
back to the overview and scrutiny
or are you more inclined to allow the
overseer scrutiny decision
committee to make that decision at that
time can you please clarify your own
wish councillor bromwich for a task
convention group to be included
so we have clarity for the public record
department recorded vote
thank you councillor bromwich i think
the recorded vote has already been
proposed
and seconded as such by uh capital
pertiguella and councillor
um rolfe seconded that
request chairman there's
yes i i need to understand what exactly
we're voting on because
as far as i'm aware from my
understanding it is at the
question has been the recommendation
that the cabinet has been
mended by councillor bromwich
and um backed up by a number of other
councillors
that there should be a reference to the
overview and scrutiny with
a a task and finish therefore we are not
reject we're not voting i would um
i would um outline uh on
rejecting this motion noted motion what
we're
voting on it seems to me is that
we have got an amended motion that it is
to go to overun scrutiny
therefore not rejecting the cabinet's uh
motion that's my understanding so i need
to understand
exactly what i'm voting for if it's to
vote if it's to reject as
cabinet says i'm voting against but if
it's to go to cabinet
to over in scrutiny and have a task and
finish then i'm supporting
councillor junit um i'm minded to look
at
page 56 myself where we have the first
recommendation
and where it says that
uh and ends with and set up a task
unfinished task group and delete
number two that the notice of motion is
rejected
would that have your support
the so you we are not rejecting
uh rejecting this we are actually uh
positively supporting it going to over
and scrutiny committee
for a task and finished group two to uh
judge on it
my my reading of the recommendation i'll
just i'll read it in full
recommended to council that the overview
and scrutiny committee review
the warwickshire county council report
on food poverty and invite
county council officers to a future
meeting in order to discuss further
and to set up a task and finish task
group
does that meet and the item
and therefore is deleted
yes please chairman
mr butler yeah chairman i i think
they're not
mutually exclusive i think they can both
stand and that the cabinet did consider
the moses motion and did reject
it but also proposed the the other
recommendation at the same time
i i i would um like a view from the
the monitor officer on that particular
point please
mr buckland mr grafton i think you have
alternatives here
in the sense that either you can have
recommendation one as amended
plus recommendation two or alternatively
you could have recommendation one as
amended
without recommendation two in other
words recommendation two deleted
it depends what members are putting
forward my recollection is that council
of
councillor bromwich put forward what i
thought was
the former recommendation as a motion
that is an amended recommendation one
plus three plus that the notice be
rejected
that's what i assumed but i but if he
did
i haven't heard anybody second that as
yet
i think we're gonna have to go back to
members to to ask someone to
give us a motion that can then be
seconded
often this really does tend to uh
indicate that uh
amendments should definitely be put into
the chat so we can all see the words
which are being prepared and proposed
rather than trying to think on our feet
uh when we're in a virtual meeting
i would like to propose then please if
you don't mind
i'd like to propose that we accept um
recommendation one as amended and that
we reject
the sect the number two uh ask for that
to be deleted
that is an amendment to the original
amendment is anyone seconded
council of june ed's comments just then
please
indicated in the chat i have chair i
have seconded them
thank you councillor together right
we've got a
an amended recommendation from council
jr seconded by captain berta geller
chair you have a second for the original
amendment by councillor
trump uh for councillor bromage you have
a second of a councillor promises
amendments i can see in the chat i would
like to see
council of bromwich's uh amendment in
writing so that we can all fully
understand it because i think
without a shadow of a doubt there is
confusion amongst all members
and it's not actually been written down
which of course is normally a
requirement that we
do have and if we were in the chamber it
would be written
sure could i request a five minute
recess then to allow councillor bromage
to get something in writing he was
clearly trying to speak and type at the
same time it might be helpful for him to
have a minute or two to
to get his thoughts in writing and as
can cancel a junior
in terms of any amendment of her own
that would seem to be
the most pragmatic way forward that we
just have a quick recess to allow
everybody to get something
put down in writing
uh fully accept that council of
pemberton uh useful to have a five
minute adjournment thank you
chairman
members a lot of comments have been made
in the chat
we are trying to decipher everything but
the most recent comment there which i'm
picking up on
is that councillor bromwich has agreed
let's go for it
so i'm about to invite councillor
bromwich
to give the form of
words vocally that he is happy with
and i then intend to go to councillor
june ed to see if she is
seconding whatever council of bromwich
comes out with
and if those that item is then proposed
as an amendment to that which is before
us
on page 56 and it is seconded by
councillor juned
we will then put that to the vote if it
is
if it wins that's the end of the matter
if it falls
then my intention is to go back to the
recommendation that is before us on page
56. so
councillor bromwich um can you read out
or
vocally give the words of your proposed
amendment so propose this that we accept
the recommendation
from the cabinet on the basis base of
the original motion is sent to
the overviews and scrutinies committee
to consider
the walter county council report along
with the setting of a tuscan fencing
group
that with which theo's as part of this
but
they as would then go the overviews and
scrutineers would review
to watch a county council report on food
poverty
with a task convincing group to be
appointed to discuss
options available to stratfor district
council
which does not duplicate the work of
boyce county council
thank you councillor bromwich councillor
juned
is that wording to your satisfaction
it is on the understanding that um that
that
the original motion is not rejected this
is the
the final proposal is that this is going
to overuse scrutiny
for a task and finish group to to to
look at the options
thank you so may i clarify that that
amendment is an amendment to number one
and that the amendment also requires the
deletion
of number two is that councilor
and councillor junaid's requirement wish
yeah that's correct
mr chairman can i raise a point of order
councillor harvey you may thank you
i'd like to know from the monitoring
officer
whether the council has the authority
and the power
to instruct the overview
and security committee to form a task
and finish group
or whether that is purely a decision for
the osc could i have an answer from the
monitoring officer please
thank you councillor harvey i shall ask
mr grafton to clarify that whether it's
an instruction or a request
uh thank you mr grafton uh it's a
decision for the overview and scrutiny
committee
so essentially the council is saying in
its motion that a task and finish group
we set up but it is a decision
that the overview and scrutiny committee
will be able to make
i've seen that councillor o'donnell has
been indicating
um perhaps you just wish you simply
confirmed what has just been said
thank you chad i'm just thank you i'm
just a little confused because what i
had said in my explanation to counselor
pertiguella was
that the decision from cabinet which
we'd agreed with as ovu scrutiny chair
was that the topic would come back to
ovue and scrutiny with the warwickshire
county council officers
and we would see what was already being
done and then taking on board what had
been suggested
we would see what gaps needed to be
filled it is then up to overview and
scrutiny
to say whether or not there will be a
task and finish group allocated to this
particular
subject so i'm just confused as to where
all the chewing and throwing is going
because it's there
clearly on page 56 on item one as to
what has been recommended
thank you councillor o'donnell i now
just would before going to
any vote i just wish to have uh an
indication from councillor bromwich
whether he is wanting a named vote
uh and whether he is proposing that
because obviously it was initially
proposed
well back in respect of other amendments
etc
councilor bromwich i am happy for us to
proceed without a recorded vote
unless anybody else would like one
thank you councillor bromwich
i can see that council o'reilly and
councillor cargill wish to speak
to the now proposed uh
wordage we have and i'll invite both of
those to speak but then we will
be going to a vote councillor riley
um yes in the light of what um mr
grafton has said
um should the wording say that
uh it's a recommendation from the
council to
the overview and scrutiny committee to
establish
a task unfinished group rather than the
direction
thank you councillor riley uh councillor
cargill
thank you chair uh what's wrong with the
original
um option there's nothing wrong with it
it does we've gone round around the
houses so many times now
why are we trying to tell the osc what
to do it's not it's not our
responsibility
it's the osc's responsibility and they
can also schedule it into their work
program and they may decide to defer any
of these tasks and finish groups until
we actually have
the the report from wcc or we invite the
officers in
the original on page 56 is is fine
what's wrong with it
sorry check i'm just getting a bit
frustrated over all of this
i think we're now in a situation whereby
i'll just quickly look through the
wording i can see in the chat which is
the proposal is that we accept the
cabinet recommendation
with the basis of the original motion
being sent to ons
to consider the warwickshire county
council report
along with a task and finish group set
up
and that the motion be referred to ons
for a review
of the county council report on food
poverty
with a task and finish group appointed
to discuss options available to stratfor
district council
which does not to duplicate warship
county council
and that also requires the deletion of
recommendation
to that is the uh
proposal that is the amendment that has
been posed by
council of bromwich it has been seconded
by councillor junaid we should now put
that one to the vote
and if it succeeds fine if it does not
we will come
back to the original recommendations on
page 56. can we now have a
recorded vote please uh mr butland
okay thank you chairman so at this point
we are voting on the amendment
that that council the chairman has just
um
be clarified for us and if i could ask
when we call your name whether you could
repeat your name and say
whether you are for against or
abstaining in relation
to the amendment to to the
accumulation of mccann councillor dixon
councillor dixon
against thank you councillor fitter
councillor against thank you
thank you uh councillor bomage
councillor promised
thank you councillor cargill council
cargill against
thank you councillor cleve councillor
cleve
four thank you uh councillor crump
curse of the chrome pub stein councillor
curtis
councillor curtis at four thank you
councillor eden
come on counselor
i'll come back to council reading thank
you councillor fielding
against thank you councillor fleming
cast the fleming against thank you
councillor foytec
council of fighting iv performance
council of foreman against thank you
councillor ian frenchly
councillor ian fashley thank you
councillor jenny frenchman
councillor jenny freshly
okay they've come back to council of
crunchy i know councillor harris has
left the meeting
so i'll move on to council harvey
council harvey against
thank you uh councillor henshaws helping
pencil hence yourself in four
thank you council jennings councillor
jennings against
thank you councillor junaid
absolutely nade4 thank you um
councillor kettle that's the kettle
against
thank you councillor mills housing mills
against
thank you councillor o'donnell
council donald against thank you
councillor parry
councillor parry against thank you
councillor pemberton
cancel pemberton against thank you
transport
council portugal four thank you
councillor richards
councillor richards again thank you
councillor riley
cancer riley four thank you
for brock council rock four
thank you council of wolf council roll
four
thank you councillor shenton cancer
shenton against
thank you our councilor wally hoggins
counselor wally hoggins abstain
okay thank you and now i need to return
to councillor eden
council eden for apologies thank you
and counselor jenny fragile councillor
jennifer actually
four thank you chairman
chairman i make that 15 votes
for 15 votes against
with with two extensions i'm wondering
whether the modern officer could check
my maths on that one please
thank you mr butler and we're checking
at the hour end as well yeah
david for the record i've counted the
votes as well and got the same results
as you it's tony perks yes sir
thank you
chairman me the same
chairman's passing broken jail i now
have the casting vote
and i will not change my mind i was
against that
amendment so that one falls
it will now put the original
recommendations as on page 56
to the council and again i would ask for
a
named vote uh mr butland
recorded we're now voting in relation to
the original recommendation of printed
on page 56
of the agenda again i'll call your name
if you could please indicate whether
you're voting
for against or abstaining for that
particular
recommendation um counselor dickson
jim council councillor dixon four
thank you for fitter councillor four
thank you councillor adam councillor
adam against
thank you um councilman
councillor [ __ ] against thank you um
councillor bromwich abstain
thank you councilman cargill council
cargill for
the key council of cleve council cleave
against
thank you council crump how's the crop
fort
thank you councillor curtis councillor
curtis against
thank you councillor eddon council
reading against
if you come to the field in four
counts of
counselling factually against thank you
council jenny frenchly
council the journey fragility against
thank you councillor harris's left
meeting so councillor harvey
council harvey four thank you councillor
henshaw seraphine
councillor henshaw seraphin against
thank you um councillor jennings council
jennings fourth
thank you councillor junit
councillor susan's unit
welcome back to council of unity uh
councillor kettle
cancer kettle for thank you councillor
mills
council mills for thank you councillor
o'donnell
councillor donald four the council of
harry
councillor parry for thank you
councillor pemberton
councillor pemberton four thank you
councillor
guella answered against
councillor richards iv dr richards
council of riley
riley against thank you council of rock
that's what might you want
[Music]
to
thank you i will now try again for the
council of june ed
are you with us councillors unit council
united against
thank you and councilman
council rock against
thank you chairman i make that 17 votes
for
with 14 against and one obsession
thank you mr buckland so that
recommendation
has been agreed by council we will now
move on to items from the audit and
standards committee
of the 29th of march item 10
minute 656 the local government
association model
councillor code of conduct and i
invite councillor crump as the chairman
of the audit and standards committee
to introduce this item councillor crump
thank you mr chairman hopefully this
weren't quite as lust as the previous
item which i was slightly confused about
at one stage um
this is a quite straightforward paper
that is to do
with the local government association uh
model
councillor code of conduct it's been
towards it in standards
uh and basically uh in most respects
the new lga code was very similar to the
stc one
um but it didn't enhance the strength of
them and also address the main problems
issues raised by the committee
on standards in public life ethics and
local government report
and the transparency international
report
so i would like to
uh recommend this to the council uh
there are
four items in there and uh
yeah basically this hopefully we'll
agree this item thank you mr
thank you councillor thank you for not
reading all those four recommendations
out we've
spent enough time on the last item
already uh but i now call upon a second
for those four recommendations
councillor jensen i think you're
indicating i'm just trying to catch up
on my chat
councillor shenton
thank you chairman uh yes i'm i'm quite
happy to second this it seems
an eminently sensible approach to uh
extend and tighten up some of the
controls and roll it
uh and be in line with other councils
and perishing town councils to be in
line with this it uh it makes
absolute sense extending the nolan
principles
uh respect rules uh code of conduct
training and all
and and all the other things i won't
list them um so
yes i would second this quite happily
thank you councillor shenton uh i see
that councillor junaid has indicated in
the chat that you would like to add an
amendment
i certainly hope it is a brief one uh
capital junior given the uh
the previous item that we had this
afternoon council jr
i would like to amend that we that
councillors should report any meetings
with a commercial developer even if it
is below the definition
of a major scheme thank you
is that anybody seconding uh councillor
june ed's
suggested amendment
councillor pertiguella you wish to speak
yeah i'm i i'm really pleased i'm really
pleased about
um these recommendations are very
welcome
um however i um sadly we are seeing with
a
green sea lobby scandal the marquis
issues of privilege access
preferential treatment around the
revolving door between government and
business
and this is contributing to a corrosion
of trust
and i think that is immensely important
for our residents to clearly see that we
lead
on these issues and that we want to set
high standards
in public life i ask therefore whether
it would be appropriate
because of what is happening at the
heart of national government
that the transparency international
recommendations six and seven
the which respectively looked a lobbying
and revolving door policy could be
brought
back to the audit and standards
committee
um to be discussed again thank you
thank you councillor peter geller i see
that uh we've got several people
indicating a desire to second the
amendment from councillor juned
um councillor shenton you appear to be
first on my list
uh perhaps you can confirm that's the
situation
i think i'm first on your list because i
seconded didn't i
ah sorry sorry councillor jensen so
uh quite happy to speak again but i'm
with you
councillor curtis perhaps you were
seconding the amendment from
council junior councillor curtis
yes sorry thank you yes i'm very happy
to
second the amendment by councillor
junette
thank you thank you councillor curtis
councillor riley you've also indicated a
desire to second obviously picked about
to the post by councillor curtis
would you like to comment council
o'reilly
um only the time willing to second
council of june this amendment
thank you council right councillor
pemberton uh as indicated to speak and
then councillor harvey
uh councillor pemberton first
thank you chairman i'll i'll try to be
brief um
first just a personal statement uh just
for the avoidance of any doubt
whatsoever
um uh uh in my role
from the place perspective um i
am regularly invited to discussions by
um and promoters of developments of all
shapes sizes and types whether they be
housing or employment
and it is good practice
and it is a practice i support and
follow the officers should be in
attendance
for those meetings absolutely
foursquare behind the nolan principles
i quite understand where councillor
juned is coming from
in terms of wanting to ensure that we
uphold the very best of standards and i
would support that
um i just wonder whether however the law
of un unintended consequences might come
into play
as i understand uh what councillor
junity is proposing for her amendment
that would require every single member
every ward member
if they have a meeting with some with
somebody bringing forward an extension
that may need
require planning permission to re record
that meeting
um potentially to have an off and for to
have an officer
in attendance um i'm just not entirely
certain that that is what is
intended here because that would seem
to go significantly beyond
what the local government our
association are envisaging
um and that would seem to to create
quite an
onerous duty to be for officers to
support
absolutely any conversation with any
commercial organization around any
development
whatsoever and i do wonder whether that
is exactly
what um counselor tuner intends
here if canceled unity's intending to
um to want the law
and i noticed a comment but it's a
commercial developer you know a
commercial agent can bring these things
forward for
a householder i think we do need some
clarity and
um it might be something that actually
if can't
if if there's some refinement that
perhaps counselor junior might want that
to go back toward it and standards
uh i just think that as it's as it's
framed at the moment
it is it is not what's intended and
perhaps it might be better for a further
discussion if there's any movement on
going beyond major applications that
audit and standards consider that
because i'm not sure on the uh in the
middle of this meeting we could actually
get to agree what definition should be
there
uh that would be my observation i would
struggle to support an
um an amendment that sort of opened it
up in such a way
thank you thank you councillor pemberton
certainly today is showing the uh the
problems of
of absence and difficulties when we are
no longer face to face
um because certain accounts from the
june 8 i think
the proposal reading the chat is it was
in respect of only commercial
development and not household
development but again that could
uh presumably require some uh more
tighter definition
uh that said i can see the council
counselor please yes yes indeed at the
moment it says where ten or more homes
will be provided
um if a commercial developer wanted to
do
five houses or nine houses uh
they should also record report to the
planning officers
that such a uh a meeting has taken place
it's just for um clarification they
don't need to
uh go into a lot of depth but it's just
making it public
that they've had meetings
so for clarification for my own mind
counselor junaid even if it was
one commercial property or
house being developed that would be your
comment comment because obviously you
just referred to five or three
uh does it go as low as one yeah
it is just to make it sure i mean i
personally never meet any developer
whatsoever
of any shape or form or any at all um
it's just a role that i've always made
for myself um
but um i i just think we just need to be
absolutely above uh suspicion by members
of the public so that's why i proposed
it
your personal attitude uh is to be
commended uh but certainly a situation
where my members obviously able to make
their own
minds up but we do have a need to
clarify matters exactly what we may be
voting on in a moment's time
uh councillor harvey i think you've
indicated to speak please
thank you mr chairman
um this afternoon has been
an exercise in finding out the frailties
of trying to fly by the seat of your
pants
in my view um councillor junid's
uh proposed amendment uh was
she used the word any development and
she does mean
any development and i think that's an
abrogation of the role and
responsibilities the audit and standards
committee because i presume
that in coming to their recommendation
the audit and standard committee did
consider
alternatives um
for those of us who've sat on a planning
committee we know that
uh housing anybody coming forward with a
housing development
pro proposition is the developer in
other words
the applicant for an extension to his
house
is a developer as far as planning law is
concerned
if this was done on the seat of the
pants
basis of changing it to any
uh developer that would impinge upon
the ability of ward members to be able
to do their job
in my view and i echo the sort of
comments that
uh councillor pemberton made that
the thought of a ward member having to
involve
a an officer of the council to discuss
um a local housing needs house
for instance in in a village as a
one-off
development it is a nonsense frankly
and um if we're not careful we are going
to make ourselves
a bit of a laughing stock there is
nobody
on this council who is in favor of low
standards
of double dealing of um
doing things which they shouldn't do i i
wouldn't
impugn the position of any counsellor
on this councillor in that regard at
best
i would leave it to the audit to the
audit and standards committee
to have note of this discussion and
reconsider
if they wish but i work on the basis
that this recommendation has been the
subject of
forethought and analysis and has come
forward
for good reason and i'm quite happy to
support it
as it is and avoid the bureaucratic
nightmare that would entangle ward
members from doing their job
if the amendment were approved thank you
thank you councillor harvey uh i've got
another five councils i think i've
indicated but i've also
had a request from mr grafton so i shall
ask phil
if you'd like to speak to it before we
uh continue with our comments
mr grafton yes thank you chairman it's
just a clarification really because what
i heard
um catholic junit propose originally
was that she was asking that members be
required to report to the planning
service
whether any meeting had taken place with
a commercial
developer in respect of an individual
planning application
but since councillor harvey has also
introduced what um a notion that
that what she was talking about was also
making sure and council official
was with her was with the member um
i just wanted clarification from
councillor junior whether that was her
intention
also to extend it so that an officer was
in attendance regardless of the number
of
properties being built thank you the
council of general thank you mr grafton
the counselors yes
i ask that they should report uh any
meetings that's all i asked for
thank you thank you councillor juliet so
that's clarified the situation where my
officers aren't necessarily
aren't going to be required to be in
attendance
for meet councillor juned's request it
is merely that
members make the council aware of such
meetings occurring whether or not
uh irrespective almost of the size of
the commercial
development uh right i should now move
on to
my third speaker which is councillor
cargill
thank you chair uh well i think castle
harvey and council of pemberton have
actually summed
up what i was about to say and thank you
very much indeed for that
gentleman um just to finish on my
very short note i think that all
members here and i haven't seen any
abuse of
the powers that members have here uh in
that respect
i've never seen anything like it so i
don't necessarily think that we are in a
position
of having to put in extra rules and such
like
and i've got to say it i think that the
reference to
green hill and the government is faintly
ridiculous
and i just find that quite offensive
thank you
thank you councillor cargill uh council
of bromwich you're next in my list
yeah i think when we look at this we
have to look at it from a bit of a
realistic sort of point of view so if we
were to
adopt councillor junior's amendment he
would be my concern
i'm out on the thursday night that and
a friend of mine who may or saw a friend
of my friend's mind who may be in the
building trade may turn around
and start discussing some sort of
development with me
down a drinking establishment now would
i be obliged to report that or not i
could see
various little issues creeping in there
i think when we're talking about less
than 10 houses
or extensions or any other sort of
development
we can apply a bit of common sense
counselors here and if we think
that it is important that we make it
known that we've spoken to somebody
we can simply just turn around tell the
plan officer i've had a chat with
somebody
for example i would give an example over
the weekend when i was
busy at southern cricket club a person
in the building trade
asked me my thoughts about a building
in another area and that which narrow
which i
know very well no and whether he thought
it would be better as
a commercial development or a housing
development it involved a couple of
buildings
that and i turned on my it was a
personal comment which was well
personally i think you'll make a very
nice house
and i don't think it's much good for a
commercial property anymore now would i
have to report that impromptu
thing although it's not that relative to
my ward
or not this is where you start getting
some mucky waters
no because it's actually have no real
outcome on what they decide in the end
they're just asking
a friend of a point of view that and i
think
from what council harvey said council
pemberton so councillor cargill said
and i think what we should all know is
if if we
think that we may be getting unduly
pressured
influenced that then yes we do have
proper reporting mechanisms
if we think it is a casual conversation
like do you think i can get six foot
extension on the ounce or not
i think that's the sort of thing we
should be writing registering down
on the thing because ultimately that
we're probably not going to have much of
an
impact on that sort of thing larger
developments i can understand why you'd
want to turn around to declare it
but when it gets to something small
scale i think just
common sense is needed we don't need to
write it into a rule if we think it's
appropriate we can notify but if we
don't
we just don't do we're just making lots
of paperwork and lots of
extra work for a lot of people for no
real reason
that and if we were taking backhanders
out like i know councillor crump
apparently is a multi-millionaire now
if you believe social media for that
of it and so all the rest of us sitting
on this council
now we're probably going to be holding
our meetings in barbados cove it's
restricted lifted
then you could say we've got a problem
but i concur with councillor cargill
my time in this council i have never
known any counselor
to have clandestine meetings with
developers builders that and they
haven't if they have met with these or
people they've always talked freely
about it whether they've agreed with
them or disagreed with them
and i don't think that sort of behavior
goes on in this council
it would be like accusing officers are
doing on towards things i know we have a
spot to him and arguments
but i will turn around say from
experience all my time on this council
this council is very well run it's a
very honest bunch of people
that sometimes we have disagreements
sometimes we don't
we have major fallouts whatever and that
but on the whole
i've never seen any hint of any
corruption in this council
and i don't think we need to be adopting
this amendment we just need to use
common sense
thank you councillor bromwich uh the
next uh councillor on my
list is well it would have been
councillor crump but uh councillor trump
as the proposal i'm going to bring you
in at the end
to speak on this particular amendment uh
so i should now move through to the
kettle speaking to this amendment
thank you mr chairman um i
support the position set out at length
by councillor bomage
uh and also by council cargo and council
pemberton
and what we have to remember as well is
at the end of the day
um contentious applications are made at
planning committee
um and it is up to the counsellor
at that stage if he has a conflict of
interest
to disclose that um that that
uh interest um and therefore those
people sitting on the planning committee
will will uh if they have not disclosed
that interest will not have an interest
and therefore not be party to
any any suggestion or inappropriate
suggestions from the developer
i have never been on a planning
committee where i have not seen
at least one member at some stage stand
up and say
i have a conflict of interest and i will
not be taking part on that
um so um
you know i i what i think this is is
using an example
in london which is a long way away of
something where one person
or maybe more have acted inappropriately
may have we don't know and using
that particular brush
to paint the same position over every
counselor in this council i think that
is completely inappropriate
thank you thank you councillor kettle
the last uh one to
speak is councillor fielding and then i
shall go back to councillor crumb
uh has the fielding thank you chairman
i would like to see this come back to um
audience standards there are certain
weaknesses in it
that i'm i have discussed with the
chairman
there's for instance there is the fact
that sometimes
i've sat down with um the wrcc to
discuss affordable homes
and she's brought in one of one of the
developers
um we haven't got a particular site
there's often the question coming
forward in parish council meetings
where they're looking for affordable
homes could i give them any
comment any advice um it's a difficult
one and there's a lot
and the other thing i i find difficult
to
comprehend is having had a few problems
with parish councils
who have got their own code of conduct
um surely we it's very difficult to say
this got to be accepted by the parish
councils
when they're an entity unto themselves
so i
i find it difficult to accept this
um but i would propose that it gets sent
back to
audition standards thank you
thank you councillor fielding uh two
more councillors have indicated since i
last spoke to
councillor curtis and that will be
followed by councillor fly check
councillor
curtis thank you sir um just responding
to counseling headless comments
um i don't think anyone is seeking
to i think paint any counsellor
in this council with any particular
brush of any
color at all and i honestly don't see
the harm in requiring i'd like to
to see what harm there is actually
in requiring counsellors to report
meetings as proposed i think residents
are
disenchanted with politicians both
locally and
nationally and to me it seems perfectly
reasonable though some may find it
rather sensitive
for councillor perth together to draw
attention to corruption
of this conservative government and the
need for us
to distance ourselves from it as far as
possible thank you
thank you councillor curtis councillor
fight check you wish to speak
thank you chair yeah i'm on the audience
standards committee and i remember
speaking about this particular
part that um an amendment
is being you know asked for and
um this was actually added to actually
give a definition of what a major
development
is and it was spoken at length
by the committee and it was if i
remember rightly it was voted on
unanimously to actually adopt that so
i think to actually um make amendments
to it now
um it isn't going to bring anything to
the table so um
i won't be supporting the amendment
thank you
thank you counselor if i check uh that
brings an
end to the members which you've
indicated and now i should go back to
councillor crump who was the initial
proposer
because obviously before we put the
amendment to the vote
we must uh hear from the proposer of the
initial
recommendations councillor graham
thank you mr chairman um oh sorry i did
um
fight saying that this wouldn't go on so
long so i apologize for that i will keep
my
mouth quiet in the future at point of
learning and
uh mr chairman enough i do uh i will
happily put
not a pound in your bucket i will put 10
pounds so i do apologize for that
sincerely um yes i'm very concerned
about the comments
uh about corruption uh about the
government
um i would like to see the facts
behind that so again i think that
comment uh
you know is um i don't know i i don't
necessarily agree with that comment and
i'm not sure whether my residents are
disenchanted with me
in terms of transparency etc so it might
be something
further west of the district but i think
in the east of the district i don't
think our
our councillors uh the residents are
disenchanted especially with the with
the joint fight between labour
so lib dems conservatives
and independents regarding hs2
so yeah i'm certainly uh i'm quite
disappointed about that
there's one thing in the report i'm not
sure everybody read the original report
that went to audit and standards it's
it's the second recommendation
regarding uh paragraph 1.14 in the
original
proposal uh where there was something
coming back
to the joint the two committees at sdc
and wdc um with proposals for joint
arrangements
uh and various things but there's two
items on there
uh harmonation harmonization of visual
forms
and other documents ancillary to the
joint arrangements
says possibility uh things to do with uh
lobbying
etc it could be included in that that's
another opportunity
and we've also the final point i think
cancer the vortex might remember
issuing guidance to assist members in
complying with the lga
code so i think we already cover a lot
of these points
and i thought we had a great debate at
the audit and standards and i would say
that some chair so
again apologies for being biased but it
was a cross-party consensus on that
um and i think others will agree with
that so
i think what we came forward was a
sensible unreasonable conclusion
we've got the opportunity for things to
come back to
um uh is to come back uh
to the ordinance standards uh to wda
osdc and whatever it's called at
wdc so i think we've covered this
properly
and i think we should go forward with
the original proposal
thank you councilor crump um i see there
has been a request
from councillor pemberton for for
mr grafton to clarify a point of order
the best convene
can councillors make an allegation of
corruption against her majesty's
government um
uh mr grafton would you like to make a
comment on that please
[Music]
yes thank you chairman so what what i
heard
although i might be mistaken was that
there was
a suggestion of um perhaps corruption
at government level if we're thinking
about definite defamation
then that doesn't meet the requirement
because
in order to infringe defamatory rules
were talking about naming
someone um i don't know whether
uh counselor curtis would want to
reflect on
what he did say but all i can say at the
moment is i don't see any sort of
unlawfulness in what's being said and i
would see this very much as part of
the political debate thank you
thank you thank you for clarifying mr
grafton
i should now ask uh councillor shenton
who seconded the original proposal if
you'd like to make any comment on the
amendment
and then i think we will put the
amendment to the vote
uh councillor shenton thank you chairman
uh understandably
i am not in favor of the amendment at
all
councillor curtis especially seeks to
expand or make aspersions if you like
about corruption in government without
any proof at all and tries to extend the
argument
along with cancel a pair together uh and
and the use of such a language is
inflammatory to say the least and not
helpful
as councillor crump has already stated
as chairman of the
audit and standards committee this had
cross-party
agreement i failed to understand
why there should be an amendment
if it had cross-party agreement are we
saying are the liberals saying they
don't trust their own members
on on the audit and standards uh
committee to come to the right
conclusion as i say i find the i find it
quite offensive the language that's
being used by a couple of the
councillors and i feel
that the amendment should be rejected
and the original proposal
should be put to members thank you very
much
thank you councillor shenton i i won't
be coming to councillor curtis who's
already
spoken in respect of this amendment um i
would now go to
councillor rock with his point of order
which uh hopefully might move
on to a vote but councillor rock your
point of view
hopefully well because having listened
to various members speaking they seem to
be
talking about something else other than
counselor june had said
as i understood what she said
she made a recommendation which i took
to be for the protection of councillors
rather than anything else
the discussions that took place
with developers commercial developers
should be recorded in some way by
implication by
sending an email or something and
other members seem to have read it that
it was involving
officers or involving a lot of
bureaucracy it
i understood what we are going to be
voting on
if if if i'm correct
is uh a recommendation to
members it was nothing more than that a
recommendation that members
should record any discussions they have
with developers
uh and just making a note of it that it
had taken place and that
i read that to be for the protection
members that's what i understood the
amendment was
and a lot of discussion has taken place
which appeared to be about something
else i think i think
could we just clarify what council of
juliet has recommended channel i think
that'll be worth doing before we
went any further i hope that's helpful
thank you council rock i intended to
clarify that before going to the vote
but mr grafton is rick
asked to speak so over to you phil and
then we'll
ask susan to be clear in the exact
wording of her amendment
uh count mr grafton thank you chairman
so i
i a number of um times we've had in this
meeting
um people wanted to put forward
amendments but it being not
wholly clear to other members exactly
what those amendments were
now we have a rule in our council
procedure rules that
says as a general principle you're
required to actually put in writing
your amendment um obviously counselor
junit
will probably properly clarify exactly
the wording of her amendment
but i will be making sure that in future
meetings we are dear to that rule
because i don't think it's fair
for people to be um
in any doubt about what they're voting
on thank you
thank you mr grafton obviously we did
have those comments at the very start of
this meeting but uh obviously members
have
and these virtual meetings believe you
me uh the sooner we get back to face to
face the better
uh councillor junaid
yes indeed i was just trying to put it
into the into the chat
it my amendment was just really for the
protection of councillors
camden councillors should report any
meetings with a commercial developer
even where a development falls below the
definition of a major scheme
i just felt it was full protection of
councillors quite honestly
and that's all my intention was when i
put forward the amendment
thank you councillor junaid
we now have clarification as to the
intent
of that amendment and now we will put
that amendment
to the vote uh and i think we've said
a named vote yes a roll call
so it's a roll call vote uh mr butler
thank you chairman
so once more if you could please and
indicate whether you are voting for
against or obtaining for the amendment
as football councillor junior
councillor dixon councillor dixon
against
thank you councillor peter councillor
against
thank you councillor adam councillor
adam four
thank you councillor [ __ ] council clock
four thank you um councillor bombach
councillor probably thank you councilman
cargill
because the cargo against thank you
please counselor cleave for
trump here's the trump against
thank you council curtis
quicker than i thought
[Music]
against thank you councillor ian
princely
absolutely and tragically paul thank you
councillor jenny frenchly
councillor jenny fragile for thank you
councillor harvey
council harvey against thank you castle
hunter seraphin
thanks for answering four thank you
councillor jennings
else earnings against thank you castle
jeanette
yesterday thank you
councillor parry against thank you
councillor pemberton
councillor pemberton against the
amendment thank you councillor
keller councillor
together thank you
thank you rock
because i'm nigel welk
welcome back to nigel ii councillor
uh councillor of uh four thank you
councillor shenton
councillor shenton against thank you
councillor wally hoggins
councillor wally hoggins against thank
you and
can i come back to nigel rock nice are
you there you fought against abstaining
chairman i i have no response from
councillor um
rock i've already got 19 votes for with
11 votes
sorry 19 votes against with 11 votes
four
so it wouldn't be material to vote in
any case
so that amendment is lost thank you
thank you mr butland
i now go back to the original
recommendations as
on page 58 were initially proposed by
accounts for trump and seconded by
councillor shenton
i will now have a roll call on that one
please
uh mr buckland chairman said we're
taking recommendations one to four on
page as printed on page 58
again if members of council could please
indicate whether they're poor against or
abstaining
forward the substantive uh
recommendations so councillor dixon
councillor dixon four thank you
councillor
councillor fitter for councillor
council cargill 4 thank you councillor
cleve
councillor cleve four thank you
councillor crump
against the crump for thank you
councillor curtis
councilman curtis four thank you
councillor evan
counselored
four thank you guys like you and french
lee
council ian fletcher four thank you
council jenny frenchly
councillor jennifer lee four thank you
councillor harvey
that's la harvey four thank you again
for hensha seraphin
thanks for answering for thank you
councillor jennings
councillor jennings for thank you
councillor junit
answered your name for thank you tesla
kettle
tesla cattle for thank you kessler mills
council mills for thank you councillor
o'donnell
councillor donald for thank you
councillor parry
councillor parry four thank you
councillor pemberton
councillor pemberton
thank you council richards
castle richards four thank you council
o'reilly
council rightly fourth thank you guys
lebron
that's the major walk you back in the
meeting
okay councilman rolfe councilworld four
thank you council center
accepted thank you uh thank you mr
washland
uh we can now move on that uh those
recommendations have now been agreed by
council
and we can move on to item 11 which is
another item from the audit and
standards committee
already discussed on the 29th of march
and it is item 11
minute 657 independent person an
extension of term of office
and i invite councillor crump to
introduce this item
councillor crump thank you ken i'll see
it's
election season so uh i won't say much
that the report is
just what it says on the tin cross party
support on this eventually
um and seeking uh
for uh to appoint mr mike dunn as an
independent person
be extended from the first of july 21
for a period of four years to the 30th
of june 2025.
thank you thank you councillor crump can
i
invite the second head to that uh
proposal
house for the fielding you've indicated
first council of fear me
i'm happy to second the report which
went before the
the committee when i was present
against the fielding been proposed and
seconded the recommendation to council
i'll just leave it a moment in two
for anybody to comment in the chat if
they don't
it will be an agreed item
nobody's indicated thankfully so minute
11
item 11 minute 657 has been agreed by
council
you can now move to items from the
cabinet meeting of the 12th of april
and it's uh item 12 minute 691 the
course
strategy review and i invite councillor
pemberton as deputy leader of the
council to introduce
this item that's le pemberton thank
thank you chair and members will be
aware that
uh on reaching the five-year point after
adoption of the core strategy
that um we are required to carry out
an assessment uh the purpose of which is
to uh
establish whether the the local plan the
course strategy remains
up to date members uh uh
have in front of them the report which
confirms in officers opinion
that the core strategy is indeed up to
date the findings of the review
assessment to set out in appendices one
and two to the agenda report
the course strategy is up to date he's
not open to challenge
um and remains a sound basis for
planning decisions
and i i commend the recommendation to
council
to establish that fact and send that
clear
and unambiguous message that the core
strategy in place is
absolutely robust and is defendable
um and i now will leave that and look
for a seconder
for uh the recommendation that i have
put to
council thank you thank you council of
pemberton
uh so councillor junaid you wish to
raise a question the
the only question was that given that
there is
a lot of um a lot of proposals being
made by
government at a national level on
changing
various planning legislation that if
anything occurs
uh that will impact on this assessment
that we will be notified as soon as
possible uh i'm not
i'm not thinking that that would happen
but i just want to be sure that
it will be taken into consideration just
to clarify
chair there is absolutely nothing
whatsoever in any government guidance
published or pending that would impact
on this assessment
and of course officers do keep changes
in legislation updates from
mhclg decisions by planning inspectors
and
any other um influential decision
to ensure that our planning policies
remain robust
and defendable that's that's just part
of the
the day job and of course members uh can
be assured
that were anything to change uh that
that would be brought forward
um with no undue delay whatsoever
but to repeat the message there is
nothing whatsoever that impacts on the
assessment of
the robustness and uh soundness of the
core strategy at the five-year point
thank you
thank you thank you councillor pemberton
and thank you captain junaid i see a
council of promises indicated to speak
and i think perhaps second the uh the
proposal from council of pemberton
councillor bromwich
yeah i'm more than happy to second this
proposal
i don't know how many councils actually
saw it last week but um
national government actually released
figures saying
85 percent of councils who had
adopted local plans had not complied
with this five-year requirement
review so i think this is a great
testimony to
how well this council is actually run
and he's trying to keep this core
strategy
up to date and legally sound and i think
credit to
everybody involved when we start
thinking that we are
one of 15 of local authorities
who adopted plans and that they're
actually keeping on top of it
and i think as a whole now all those
councils should say big congratulations
to everybody involved
uh with your forebear and share may i
just say thank you to councillor bromage
and i will ensure that his
remarks are passed on to the officers
who've put all the hard yards in on this
work and i'll make sure that your
comments are made known to them thank
you councillor bromage
thank you yeah so kemberton uh i see
that council of fielding has
indicated a second um and obviously i
indicated that time spotted it under
council of promise
caster fielding did you wish to speak to
this one and i'd already spoken it was
the one before
uh but i'm quite happy to second it um
i i work very hard with the core
strategy find it very useful
and it does make sense so i'm happy
thank you council of folding it's
surprising what uh the chat throws up as
by way as
uh who's said what and who's questioning
and seconding etc
so it was indeed i'll take counselor
bromwich as the uh
secondary to council of pemberton if
nobody else wishes to speak on this i'll
just give chatham a moment to uh
to come to life other than that the item
will be agreed
right that has agreed having been
proposed by council of pemberton and
seconded by council of remitch
and is now approved finally we now move
on to the other
items coming to council item 13
councillors
questions we have received 22 questions
all of which have been circulated and
published on the council's website
additionally with the exception of
council of bromwich's questions which to
be honest
counsellor we're just too long to be
incorporated they are
all on the teams and will be displayed
on the screen
together with the responses so the first
question i have is to cancel a branch do
you have a supplementary question
counselor
i certainly do um first of all this is
the second meet in a row where i don't
seem to be able to get
a proper response so
having as council penta will know he's
had a fair bit of flack off me
over the past few weeks so i'm very
disappointed first of all that he's now
got to take the flack
again for the response from the leader
of the council
which in particular two crucial areas
was in relation
to the leader of the council claiming a
bid for the town center
regeneration from west midlands combined
authority
and council of pendleton responded last
month on that saying
no bid had been submitted but there had
been a bid
through spa on this part here
yet the leader seems to think that they
haven't contradicted themselves the
leader's position
was over a period of time from november
2018
right up to councillor penton's response
a bid had been submitted and
won a first round ballot and he was
hearing to hit wait until back from a
second round ballot
he then turned around 12 months ago and
said this was held up
by kobe eventually when councillor
pendleton gives him
there was no such they never
it never and there was no kovid related
thing so when i asked
who is accurate with their information
the leader or the deputy leader
for my initial assessment it would be
the deputy leader
and i think the leader should explain
how over the period of time
he has got things so badly wrong
and he really should be answering to the
council on this
the other points made in this question
were when councillor pemson mentioned
about pacific projects
and council jefferson has also brought
up the same issues here as leader and
deputy leader and
policy council pemberton's portfolio
holder from august 2017
right through to just before kobe
january of last year
myself and council trump have met
several times and given
projects myself councillor crump
and councillor connors of southern town
council met with the leader
and given a project of this so to say we
haven't come up with ideas it's
absolutely
ridiculous we've not had the support
through the count
through the leadership of the council in
my opinion here
so when are we actually going to get
this support the final part is a matter
of trust
we have two big conflicting differences
of opinion here
is it counselor pendleton who is correct
as it is looking like in writing
or is it counselor jefferson who is
correct which he's not looking good on
that is a serious issue how can people
inside them
have trust in the leadership of this
council
when there are two big conflicting
answers to a question and
i'm sorry council pemberton to have to
put you into the position to have to try
and respond to that
because i know the combined authority
thing was not of your making
thank you councillor bromwich certainly
uh i seem to pick up about three or more
questions in that as a single
supplementary
but i'll ask councillor pemberton to see
if he can respond
councillor pemberton uh thank thank you
chair
and uh um uh cancer thank you councillor
bromage my my shoulders are broad
and uh uh i am i'm quite happy to
answer as best as i possibly can um
i i think um actually
we are all actually saying the same
thing um
in the sense that um there was an
understanding that there would be a
second round of funding it hasn't come
forward and kovit has played a part in
that i think
really just the the bottom line is that
where there is an opportunity to secure
some funding that would benefits
council of bromwich's ward and
um and the same goes for any other award
in the district
when there is an opportunity to seek
funding
we will we will seek the opportunity to
secure that funding so
i think probably the thing there is for
a you know
to give you confidence moving forward
that um
there have been all sorts of different
uh
things of uh in in recent months where
um you know there you know there is talk
about all sorts of funding rounds
as and when something comes forward that
um
southam um is going to be a fit for
and not all funding opportunities will
be a fit for anywhere within this
district
um but where there are realistic funding
opportunities and
save them is a fit then a bid will be
made
i think the question about projects i
think that the
the missing piece is the detail around
where what pro around the delivery of
projects that are on on the list that
cancer bromide has
referred to um i am quite comfortable
about the use of
section 106 monies and sill monies as
appropriate
uh in southam and what i will do and
take forward from here is i will arrange
for um
cancer bromage and his and his uh fellow
southern member
councillor crump to meet with uh and
and if needs be involved the uh town
council at southam
uh to meet with um uh john carford
to put some flesh on the bones um so
that some of these projects can be taken
forward i i i
you know i know uh councillor edin for
example in studly is bringing forward uh
projects and has had discussion with
members and
uh sorry with officers and i think there
is there is an opportunity to take those
things forward
um and i am quite happy
to be put on the hook for the next
council meeting to report back to
members of this council
uh the outcome of a meeting between
councillors crump and bromage
with mr carford uh to try and get some
prioritization and flesh on the bones
and actually looking at where there are
some funds available to deliver on some
of these projects and i hope that
with that assurance uh councillor
bromwich will
will be happy to go back to his his
residence
thank you chair uh thank you
councilor pemberton uh bromwich you've
got the second question
can we be more uh precise please
in the asking of the question and i
would just mention to members that in
ten minutes time
we will have to vote to carry on or to
adjourn this meeting
uh councillor bromwich
yeah so supplementary on this one i find
this response
that i've been given to this actually
very surprising
apparently we're in the early stages of
a cpo
five years down the line we must have
some ideas of figures
council of pemberton it simply does not
wash with me
that after five years we wouldn't have a
clue what we could potentially end up
spending out on this by borrowing money
yes i accept we put a million pounds
five and all everything that you've put
there
but we have to now that start to know
what the real
costs are we have a leader stand up here
in january turning around and saying
money is tight we put correct we put
double the rate of
inflation on council tax it's very hard
to justify
to residents that's a three and a half
percent odd council tax rise
that in one breath and then the next
thing was and say money's tight
and then say actually we're gonna buy by
wellsborne airfield
because it's wonderful economic benefits
what they want though
is will it be a cost then if so how much
and i think council penta what i would
like to see even if you want to do this
privately
is start giving us some figures on the
questions that have been raised in this
i think that's the uh final question uh
councillor pemberton
thank you and thank you councillor
bromwich for your for your supplementary
um i i think the the point uh
councillor bromage is that this council
has resolved
to go down this route we have a policy
position to support
um the retention and enhancement of
flying functions at the airfield
um and and was councillor bromage
has to explain to his residents about
the increasing cost of delivering local
services
um i also have councillors parry and
crump
um demanding to want to know how i'm
going to save
wellsborne from having 1800 houses
dumped on the airfield because that's
the outcome if we
if we abandoned this thing um the
reality is that
um yes we do have a clue but it is only
a clue
and the the actual cost of um acquiring
developing and
moving on the airfield can only be
determined when there is an agreed
position
on the future development of the
airfield and that is part and parcel of
the discussion
that goes through the minimum memorandum
of understanding and i regret to say
that i am unable even in a confidential
briefing for councillor bromage
to get into that level of detail what i
can assure councillor bromage and all
other members is that
we are required um to come back to this
council at and
sorry i'm you're absolutely right
councillor kendall uh
i if i mentioned uh the wrong counsellor
there
uh councillor crump um and councillor
parry other that the ward members
um i would say that uh there will be a a
opportunity to uh consider
um should we decide to pull to make the
final decision around a cpa
i would say that the policy to proceed
as we have done
has the support of this council has the
port support of wells born parish
council
has the support of the two ward members
has the support of
um the the mp has the the support
of the cw lep has the support of the
department for transport and has the
support of the residents of wellsborne
um and so um i think that um we are
actually giving life to
um the needs and wants of a significant
proportion of
of of our district residents here um
and as and when um it is appropriate so
to do we will of course bring this
matter back
for a full airing uh by members thank
you
thank you councillor pemberton going on
now to question three
councillor crump do you have a
supplementary question
uh no thank you councillor trump for
being
precise councillor crump question four
do you have a supplementary question
no thank you councillor crump
excellent councillor richards do you
have a supplementary question on
question five uh no i'd like to thank
the portfolio holder for his answer
though
thank you councillor richards councillor
richards do you have a supplementary on
question six uh no similarly i'd like to
thank the leader for his response
moving on to i'll ask councillor fleming
question seven and eight do you have any
supplementaries on either question seven
or eight no chair thank you for that
i've been
i'd add all the information i need in
the answers thank you
thank you very much councillor fleming
council of foreman question nine
do you have a supplementary question no
chair i don't thank you to the portfolio
answer for the answer
thank you councillor foreman councillor
fitter do you have a supplementary
question
on question 10 or question 11. thank you
chair no i haven't got a
supplementary uh question for 10 or 11
i'd like to thank the portfolio holder
for those great answers thank you
thank you councillor it's a council of
foreman question
12 do you have a supplementary question
no chair i don't and again thank you to
the portfolio holder for the answer
thank you very much indeed councillor
foreman we're moving through these
speedily councillor edin question 13 do
you have a supplementary question
no thanks chair thank you to councillor
parry and kettle for their answers
thank you councillor eden councillor
cleve question
14 do you have a supplementary question
sorry just
uh to break the chain but yes one short
question
you won't get in there
thank you uh thank you kevin for the
answer um
i appreciate you might not have the
information to hand on this but could
you find out
if there's a difference between take up
of permits between urban and rural
rural areas and would you also be able
to possibly report that back to
overview and scrutiny by the end of the
summer with a review on the income
generated by permits including whether
there's been any
been any increase in flight tipping of
green waste
councillor shenton i'll take that away i
think that's not an
answer i'm going to uh
uh yeah i'll take that away and come
back thank you
thank you thank you councillor uh
councillor henshaw serif in question 15
do you have a supplementary question
uh no thank you chair um thank you for
the portfolio holder
thank you councillor henry seraphine
councillor pertiguella on question 16 do
you have a supplementary question
i don't have a supplementary question
but i have a clarification so
the and i thank the leader for uh for
his reply
and uh so at the beginning he said the
worst pension fund
has prepared a response to queries
around disinvesting
in fossil fuels in march 2021 this is
attached
but i've not received any attachment or
any link to to this document
chair on behalf of the leader i will
ensure that councillor pertiguella
receive receives the document and
apologies for the oversight on behalf of
the leader
many thanks for pemberton thank you
council
thank you councillor pettigel and uh
councillor pemberton councillor junior
do you have a supplementary respective
accounts of question 17.
no further question thank you very much
indeed
thank you councillor junaid councillor
peter geller question
18 do you have a supplementary question
no further question
thank you thank you counselor together
councillor cleve question 19 do you have
a supplementary question
no i do not thank you thank you council
if
councillor rock question 20 do you have
a supplementary question
beg your pardon counselor rolf not
counselor i apologize
thank you we don't look much alike do we
um thank you i don't have any further
questions
thank you yes one quick supplementary
question please
um for the councillors who sit on these
outside bodies are they allowed
uh is it acceptable to claim additional
expenses as in
travel when we're allowed to travel
again um
for city for taking their position on
these bodies
thank you councillor [ __ ] just
responding on behalf of the leader i
actually don't know
um i will i will i will i will ask the
question
of of officers uh and uh um
office uh and we'll come back to you and
copy members into the answer
thank you councillor thank you
councillor
uh olcock and uh councillor pemberton i
think the answer is going to be in the
affirmative but
that might come through in the in the
chat uh
councillor jr question 22 do you have a
supplementary
no supplementary i'm just looking
forward to a formal review of the
kobe 19 response thank you
thank you very much indeed cancer junior
moving through now ah we can't move
through to agenda item 14
until we've taken a vote to continue
uh obviously we have uh questions to the
leader
and then we have the notices of motion
so
i would suggest that we agree
to keep this meeting going for a maximum
of 60 minutes
and if we don't come through by six
o'clock then the shutters come down in
elizabeth house we all get locked out
i know that doesn't pertain to
yourselves but it does to me
uh and the uh and the staff here uh so
essentially
uh if anybody is against uh the
suggestion that we continue for an hour
can you please indicate in the chat
right nobody is indicating we can see
that the welly hoggins will need to
leave at 5
15 for understandable reasons that i
already understand
etc and counselor rolf will be leaving
as well
in due course right moving through then
to
agenda item 14 questions to the deputy
leader
councillor pemberton in the absence
obviously of the leader
there are 30 minutes available at the
meeting
and councillors are permitted to speak
no more than three
minutes counselors may ask no more than
two questions
with each question taken in turn
questions must relate to the work of the
district council
and no questions shall be allowed to
relate to questions
asked at the same meeting okay
i open it up to counsellors to ask their
question
is indicating the chat
council approach first to uh indicate
that you wish to ask a question
councillor bromwich please keep it
precise if you can yes um
obviously the deputy leader is well
aware of the impact of the
a425 closure out in this area
and now obviously group of councils are
trying hard to
get some sort of assistance um
what help could the district council
potentially give
to the most vulnerable people who have
been impacted in particular
in relation to their transporting costs
to getting to medical appointments isn't
this why i bought of hs2 we were very
vague about it
but there seems to be a lot of people
who are paying out
a lot of extra money in transport costs
and obviously we do normally have things
like u-bus
and that which are more which we know of
and we have various voluntary driving
sets but
on things like volatile driving service
there has been an increase
in the cost because the increase of
mileage so would we as account could we
as a council look at some other way
we could probably help the most
vulnerable people
thank thank you councillor bromwich um i
i am aware of the
the the work that has been being done
um by what is beginning to be
colloquially known as the southern six
uh in terms of the work in relation to
hs2
and absolutely everybody uh understands
the the the challenges that are being
brought on
our communities out that way um short
answer is
i don't know what if anything we can do
what i will say
is um if councillor bromwich will
will bear with me i will arrange for
an urgent meeting to be set up with
councillor bromage and his colleagues
to understand in more depth what you
need and to understand
what if any assistance this council can
do
or what pressure this council can bring
to bear
on hs2 to make uh make things
a great deal easier for residents i will
ensure that uh following on from uh
from this meeting tomorrow because it
will be uh given will be
probably six o'clock by the time we're
done uh that tina brown makes contact
with you to to set up an urgent
discussion
ideally sometime this week that's
fantastic thank you very much
thank you council of the pemberton
councillor bromwich uh councillor frank
jenny frankly has got a question as well
council of france uh thank you chair uh
i'm sorry the lateness of this question
i've only just got uh
information on it but i think there is a
question of fairness here
i understand that people who live in
terraced houses
and whose rubbish is collected in bags
if you want your green rubbish to be
collected
you have to pay the 40 pounds for the
collection to take place
and then you have to pay 10 pounds as i
understand
per reusable bag granted the bags are
reusable but in my experience of these
bags
they last about three four perhaps five
uh uses which means people in terraced
houses
are being doubly charged for uh green
waste collection
and as the green waste seems to be uh
accruing quite a a degree of um extra
money coming in i would actually ask
that this could be looked at
please in the view of fairness to our
residents
thank you thank you thank you councillor
fragile
um uh and in andy and in
in in fairness to response uh late
contacts
context to our uh to you raising this
matter clearly this is
the first time this i i've sight on this
matter
uh what i will do is i will arrange for
uh you to have an urgent conversation
with the portfolio holder councillor
shenton
and the operational lead officer for
this julie lewis
so that you can ensure that uh this
matter is brought to
to to their attention and um
that a a discussion an agreement about a
solution
can be brought forward and again um
given that this will be a live on
potentially alive and ongoing
matter i i will i will try to uh
although i cannot commit others
uh request that such such meeting happen
within the next week
thank you chair or even deputy leader
thank you nobody else has indicated a
question or wish to
ask a question so that is a conclusion
of agenda item 14 so we now move to
item 15 motions on notice
we have two before us today the first
once proposed and seconded
will in accordance with council
procedural rules be referred to the
cabinet for consideration and report
without
debate the second version will be
debated this afternoon
first one is the over 60s fives [ __ ]
permit and i invite councillor rolfe the
proposer of this
motion councillor rolf thank you chair i
propose the motion
thank you thank you i call for
a second on that may i uh counsel jenny
fragile
may i second the motion
you're pro you're you have seconded
the the motion indeed their counselor
fragile so it has been proposed and
seconded
it will now be uh referred to the
cabinet for consideration and report
without debate they should now move on
to the second motion of notice and it is
to turn the street lights
back on at night in warwickshire and i
invite councillor freyja the proposal of
this motion
council thank you chair um yeah i've had
some discussions
in um over the last few days and
have uh accepted a friendly motion
um on this on which i'd like to propose
and i believe that that'll probably be
coming up on the screen
from um council officers
certainly that was my hope and intention
and
it is now on the screen thank you
uh it may not be that easy to read so as
i've been
handed a paper copy i'll read it out if
i may
following the murder of london woman
sarah everard
a nationwide movement for safest streets
has erupted this movement has reached
all corners of the country
including the stratford district and
warwickshire sadly
bidford ornaven has also been part of
the news
story with the report of an attack on a
woman by a male serving
west midlands police officer this story
in london and the personal experiences
of
chloe flightcheck wanting to feel safe
on our streets in stratford
resulted in wanting to take action
chloe started a petition asking how safe
people feel on our streets at night when
the street lights went
out the response was astonishing as of
the 1st of april
3462 people had signed her petition to
turn the street lights back on in
warwickshire
over 50 women have responded with
personal confidential stories of attacks
on them
most stories have not been reported to
the police
this council supports the call for safer
streets
across our district so that women and
men can feel safe
going about their daily lives stratford
is
of course also a world-renowned tourist
destination
and we also want our national and
international visitors
to feel equally safe street lighting
is a part not but not the only component
of creating safer streets and this
council should work
with the warwickshire county council and
those parish and town councils that
operate street lighting
in many of our main aurora centres and
villages
to develop a strategy to address safety
and the fear of prime while at the same
time
recognizing both the climate change
impacts of street lighting
and the wider benefits for nature of
dark skies policies
such as that in welford on avon's
neighborhood development plan
in a way that respects the needs and the
wishes of all
of our diverse communities this council
also recognizes that good design in
planning plays a part and that the
portfolio holder for place
ensures that safest are enshrined
as a component of our new south
warwickshire plan
noting that stratford-on-avon district
council planning officers
already consult with warwickshire police
on current planning applications
this council also requests that the
portfolio hold for community safety
raises this issue at the next crime
panel to agree a strategy
with warwickshire police to support
safer streets across this district
by taking this multi-agency approach
stratford-on-avon district council
will be more effective in lobbying
stakeholders who address this urgent
issue
so that all residents particularly women
can feel safe
going from work from and to work or
from and a night out at any time during
the night
that is the wording of the what i
understand is the
friendly amendment to the original and i
uh possibly may have saved capital of
footjack from reading all that out
himself um cancel the fight check
i'll pass it back to you if you wish to
add anything to that which i've just
read out and then i'll be asking for a
second
of the amended proposal cancel the
flightcheck
thank you chair so i'd just like to give
councillors um
a couple of real-life experiences of
some women amongst nearly 50 who
contacted
um my daughter chloe feutic after
starting a petition asking
workshop county council to turn the
street lights back on
um which as of today is nearly 4 000
signatures uh the the the
uh the the woman that contacted
one of the women that contacted chloe
says that six years ago i walked home on
my own after 2am
i'd never felt fear walking on my own
until that night
i was walking home and as soon as i
turned the corner of my street
this man ran behind me and snatched my
handbag had my passport keys
purse my whole uh adult
my whole adult young life in in that bag
i ran back to see if i could find my bag
thrown on the side of the road
the man was standing by the canal
emptying my belongings
i pled for my passport and keys he kind
of took 80 pound in cash and threw my
bag back
not before asking me to have sex with
him i cried and begged
just to be left alone he left me alone
in the end i got my handbag and passport
and keys back
i was foolish for going after him and
incredibly lucky
but it could have ended much worse i
then attempted twice to see somebody at
the police station but it was shut
with no one around so i gave up and just
one other experience of another woman
that contacted
chloe foytec at the end of the end of a
night out i went
to get a taxi and there was there were
none around
so i decided to walk home which was
probably just over a mile
as soon as i got out of town all the
lights were turned off walking home late
at night is terrifying as it is
with no lights it's ten times worse i
ended up sprinting as
much of the way home as i could going
the long way round to avoid alleyways
this is the reality of many women
walking home at night
this motion i hope will go to make a
start to make our streets safer
with better communication and actions
between councils police and our local
communities
all night street lights are an important
part of
they are an important factor for safer
streets
for some areas and for street safety
um i mean another suggestion that i've
heard is
lights can be dimmed earlier in the
evening to allow all night lighting to
fulfill
sort of our environmental obligations as
well
um we have to remember it's not just
about
crime and crime figures it's it's about
how we feel when we're out on the
streets
particularly at night i'm hoping that
the warwickshire county council can look
at this motion
to start a dialogue between stakeholders
so that people can feel safer
whatever time it is whether it's during
the day or middle of the night and
just just one last point um and it's
somebody that
made a comment to me and they just said
to me it's fairly obvious
that we all feel safe walking when the
lights are on
thank you thank you councillor
check i shall now call on council orc
to uh second this
amended wording and then after that has
been seconded
i understand that uh what the council
needs to do is to agree the approval
of the amended wording prior to the
opening of the debate
so uh councillor olcott i would actually
uh come back
to you uh after you've seconded it so
that you can then speak
to the amended wording once that amended
wording has been
formally approved so council or [ __ ] if
you'd like to second the
amendment which i assume is your wish
yes it is chair thank you
i'm very happy to second the changing of
the words
thank you very much indeed now
essentially we've got the form of words
before us
uh if anybody is anything against those
words
please indicate in the chat if they do
not indicate
an objection to that wording then we
will open the debate
with that a wording of being approved by
the council
and i will go back to councillor alcock
to open the debate
nobody has indicated so council all co
you have the floor
thank you very much chair uh yeah i'm
i'm very happy to second this and i was
very grateful for council foitek for
inviting me to do so
um this is sitting very close to my
heart i have been that woman walking
home
at night and have been scared
what am i scared of i can hear footsteps
i phone my husband
i walk quicker i go home
people i've been quiet people have said
why aren't things reported 999.
what do you report you can report you
felt scared but you didn't see
anybody you couldn't hear anybody it was
because you were walking in the dark
um this to me isn't just about
people feeling safer men and women feel
safe for having the lights on
i've had it raised to me in these past
past seven days actually
that many places many homes have their
own cctv for security
they have cameras on their doorbells to
help protect their property
these don't work as well when the
streets are completely dark
and this was made apparent to one lady
who
who unfortunately was subject to a dog
theft
people broke into her home took her dog
when she went to look at the cameras it
was too dark to see anything
and dog thefts are on the rise
as is anti-social behavior in places
as is vandalism in places
turning the lights off did a lot of good
for the environment nobody's going to
question that
but people should be questioning is did
turning the lights off
made criminals uh feel safer
and made people feel unsafe
it is time to turn the lights on it is
time to make sure that this
discussion happens we need to find a way
to have the streets back to the people
who work
late at night anti-social behaviors and
anti-social hours and in this town
especially in stratford-upon-avon and in
my ward of bishop
there are a lot of them they work at the
theater and they don't finish
early they work at the cinema they don't
finish early
hospitality the local my local pub the
squirrel mentioned to me
on friday it's really dark when we close
it is and people had forgotten that in
the lockdown
i would urge this council to agree to
this motion
um it is very important for a lot of
residents
thank you thank you councillor allcock
uh councillor badamich has indicated to
speak councillor bromwich
yeah i think whenever i look at a
proposal like this i'm
first of all reminded as somebody who in
normal times pre-covered
with my dj work obviously gets very used
to coming home at very anti-social hours
on this so i actually see a lot of the
various types of behaviors are actually
mentioned when i tend to be journeying
home
the question always crosses my mind is
this down to the street lights
or is it other factors and i think while
street lights are part of a factor
there is a lot of other factors and
we probably are going to start having to
debate not just at this council
across the country about how do we get
rid of the perception
of fear and how do we make sure people
feel safe
going home it's not an easy one i can
draw on one experience for example
before the street lights went off
where there was an alleged rape in
southam which actually turned out not to
be true thank god
that but all the parts involved and that
it was only for them a bit of luck we've
tracked but that's with street light
sons these incidents happened
beforehand that and they've happened
since has there been an overall increase
well the statistics would say one thing
but their
wordings would say another
and the biggest problem we face in this
country today
is that fear factor which has come in
over the years and whether we are
telling that turn around say turn streak
lights back on it needs to be
as a big overarching project and maybe
what we should be looking as a district
council
it's not only just this motion put
before us
but to start our own proper
investigations onto what our
ward members are really thinking to
counsel us and maybe it's something we
are going to have to debate as a full
council on what those experiences are
which will probably be a novel thing
because i don't think we've ever done
anything like that but just to have a
council meeting focusing on crime and
fear of crime and the fear of victims
that and just general with our nighttime
economy it's not distracted that has
that nighttime economy
it's the surrounding towns and villages
throughout the whole district
whether you're sitting there in bishops
coming home from the butcher's arms when
the light's gone off
or the bowling green that sell them
whatever and that
it's across the board and i think we
need to start having these discussions
i understand why this motions come
before us but i think it's a small part
of a very big picture
but probably at times as a council we
don't sometimes think
actually we need to debate these a big
issue properly and come to a consensus
as a group of counselors on how we want
to proceed of this
motions are start but there's a big
picture out there
thank you council of romance apologies
against the junior i think you may wish
to make a statement
on behalf of the lib demon group if it
is this item
counselor junaid yes i i i think all of
us
uh thank the mover for bringing this
issue forward
and for the amendment um concern about
women's safety has been at the forefront
of the news agenda this year
but many of us have actually been
committed to the need to protect women
for many years
and we all need to be part of the
solution so i'm
so pleased now that there are many uh
saying that enough is enough and who
want to be part
of finding a solution and finding
various solutions
uh harassment on the street is part of a
bigger problem
last year almost two women a week were
killed by a current or former partner
and domestic
abuse affects almost one in three women
some women live in fear of some men's
violence
every day of their lives the solutions
are complex
murder abuse and harassment of women are
not random
and do not occur in a vacuum they're
part of everyday life for many
and we must continue to find solutions
as i said those
solutions are complex but we can use our
powers
and the functions of the councils to
help for example
i do know that the various architect
organizations have done much research
on planning for safety and using the the
role of planning
to encourage more safety within towns
and there are many other functions of
the various councils
that can be used to encourage and
support uh
women and make their lives safer but
also not just women
young people in general and also men in
as well we all need to feel a bit safer
i would also like to look at the county
council bringing forward and bringing
back
uh other organizations like youth
organizations youth clubs and youth
movements various there's many many
complex
uh ways to bring this forward but this
is a starter
this is a very welcome starter indeed
about addressing women's safety and i
would recommend it
and we'll be supporting this uh this
motion as it's amended
thank you councillor junaid uh
councillor kettle next
thank you mr chairman um
i support the the the motion uh as as
dra
as as revised um but i would just like
to make a couple of points uh as
portfolio hold of community safety if i
may
um and just a feedback a little bit on
some of the comments that have been made
firstly um warwickshire county council
um keep 35
of their lights on all night
um lighting on public footpaths
alleyways and psychopaths
are fulfill the criteria for all night
lighting
license lighting adjacent to operational
taxi ranks
areas adjacent to elderly people's care
homes sheltered accommodation
ae departments uh areas covered by
permanent local authority police cct
cameras um and other potential hazard
areas
roundabouts junctions central
carriageway islands etcetera
further orange county council do work
closely with warwickshire police
and if a risk area is identified
and the police wish that to be re-lit
then that happens
i haven't got the details of where that
is
but it is something which the county
council and the police work together
to ensure uh perhaps hot spots is the
wrong word for and i apologize if people
take offense of that but
um you understand hopefully what i mean
um stratfor district council itself
uh we are we are looking or applying
under the safe and a
safer streets campaign we're bidding for
funding from that um which again is to
look
to looking to reduce crime um
and clearly that includes uh the impact
of lighting
but two things one the lighting goes off
late at night and comes back on at 5 30
in the morning
and secondly the the
the group of people who suffer more on
the streets
is actually men not women so this
is we have to look at the overall
picture and ensure
safer streets are there for everybody
in the district and not just members of
one
or other um and i'm i'm i'm wary of
using whatever you use the word gender
or sex
uh because clearly it is absolutely
right that everybody should feel safe on
the streets
and everybody should feel comfortable
walking on the streets
um so i support the motion as amended
but i think it is really important that
we need as others have said
to look at a global response so i've
just seen my camera isn't done i
apologize
um we need we need to say a response not
global response but but a
response to cover all our aspects
of safer streets and that isn't just
about lighting
thank you
thank you councillor kettle uh the next
councillor to speak councillor pemberton
thank you chair i'll i'll try and keep
this brief because i see others want to
speak and we are
uh moving around to 5 30. um
first of all um i'd like to uh to thank
councillor foy check actually more
importantly cancellar forecheck's
daughter chloe
who has done an enormous amount of work
to raise the profile of this issue
amongst our residents locally and
to get it onto the front page of the
herald and i think she used to be
and i know that she has been uh i think
even today
has been on national television uh
making the case for safer streets and
for action to be taken and she's to be
commended for the work that she's she
she's done there
um and uh there's clearly a counsellor
in the in in the making there and a four
check dynasty to come
um i would like to thank cancer fojek
for the positive
manner in which he has uh uh approached
the
the the the amendment wording that that
i that i that i put
to him and also to to thank chancellor
rock for his
positive um contribution and
intervention
and as other members have said
this is a multi-faceted challenge that
we face
but we do need as an authority to do
everything that we can to ensure that
our seats
say our streets are safe um and this
this motion is is the beginning of that
journey
in that it calls for integrated work
with other partner agencies it does
particularly
require certain key actions and i have
no doubt that
members will be looking for some
mechanism by which
we can review and take this further
forward and i suspect this is something
that
could and should subject to councillor
o'donnell's uh
o'donnell's um view find its way on to
the forward work program for the
overview and scrutiny to commit
committee to look at progress
so with all with all of that and with
thanks to councillor feud check and uh
councillor cook and councillor rock uh i
think i would commend this uh
this this this amended version motion
uh to to all members and i hope that
every single member can
left in the room can can get behind and
vote for this
thank you chair thank you councillor
pemberton
uh councillor shenton you're next in my
list
thank you sharon a very very quick one
and i agree wholeheartedly with uh what
council of pemberton
has just said um i i would also
add that as uh councillor junit and
councillor
have already said is that this is the
start of a of a journey obviously
because
um the solutions
to to this particular problem or the
suggestions
have been kicking around for about 60
years
if we go back to 1961 urbanist jane
jacobs actually raised a lot of the
issues that we're talking about back in
1961
and more recently the financial tie
sorry the sunday times raise this on the
14th
and one the other key part is to make
our streets
active streets and that that means
that or activated spaces that means that
they're well used but not dominated by
static groups and that seems to be a
theme that runs through
a number of other organizations as well
but in addition we have to look at
things like clear sight lines
pedestrian priority um
as well so it is a bigger issue and i
think
it's uh it quite obviously it does
warrant
further discussion in the future but i
think it's a good amendment
a good proposal and i've wholeheartedly
support this
thank you chairman thank you councillor
shenton
uh councillor cleve is uh next on my
list
uh councillor cleve thank you chair um
i appreciate this is obviously an
emotive issue for different areas of the
district
uh i appreciate that there's rural areas
that don't want the lights back on and i
understand that
however having spoken to many of my
residents in hathaway ward
while a few of them would like them to
stay off the majority of them do
want the lights back on safer streets is
not the only issue about why we should
turn
the lights back on one resident has told
me that she works as a district nurse
on the emergency response team and has
lost count of the number of times
she's been lost in her car looking for a
house name or a door number
she's been out with really vulnerable
people waiting for ambulances
with relatives of patients and even
giving cpr when the lights have gone out
as an ex-first responder i've been there
myself her night shifts finish at
midnight but
as with most medical staff we know they
rarely finish on time
uh the emergency services are under a
lot of stress
and strain so having if having the
lights on at night even help them in a
certain
uh amount it will definitely help with
the issue
therefore as a representative of my
residence i have to stand by their
wishes so i'm in favor of the lights
going back on in my ward
uh but also as has already been said
looking at the reasons behind this
rising crime and anti-social behavior
and seeing if we can do something
about that as well so i'm happy to
support this motion as amended
thank you thank you councillor
cleve uh councillor crump and then uh
i've got uh councillor rock who's been
able to rejoin us
uh councillor crump thank you councillor
dixon obviously i was extremely shocked
to hear about the death of sarah
everard and obviously my thoughts and
convinces go to her family
and friends i agree it is a multi-agency
multi-option approach is needed and i
certainly
fully endorse a bid to the safer streets
fund
at the county i've got community safety
as part of my failure
holder and at county we've got a group
called violence against women and
girls it's doing great work uh and
lots of things have come out from that
that we need to learn from
but what i would like to mention and
obviously i'm a middle-aged man so
um i apologize if i am making
assumptions but
what i would like to mention is that we
need to champion respect for women and
girls
we've all got a role to play in this
cancer schools parents guardians peers
role models etc
and i think if that respect was there
hopefully we would see some improvements
as well
like in all things in life respect costs
nothing
so i'll fully endorse this motion and
hopefully please
uh we will everybody show each other
a lot more respect thank you thank you
councillor
uh councillor rock please uh thank you
chairman
um well i start off by
as others have done uh thank you thank
you that well
i suppose the project family for for
bringing this item forward
uh and i i particularly pick out some of
the things other counts have said which
generally speaking i agree with all of
it
uh councillor june and summed up very
well what councillor crump
i absolutely agree with what's just been
said uh and i would also thank everybody
darren and myself have had particular
conversations and
i think we've massaged the words if i
can put it like that
to to produce something that's a very um
a very
good uh a good motion um what
what i would just guard against with
this fear of crime
i think is is is probably a real thing
that we need to come back
more than actual crime obviously as
as andy has said we our hearts go out to
anybody that's been
the victim of any violence in this way
however turning the lights on does not
not automatically
make us safer um in fact that the
research data
perversely goes against natural
expectations and in fact
particularly in the case of antisocial
behavior antisocial behavior
bizarrely can be made worse by lighting
so
we have to bear in mind it is a complex
issue
it needs a research which this motion
brings forward
so i think we all should support it uh
we're not sending a message that turning
the lights on
automatically makes everything all right
as andy has just said
it's a much wider problem and we need to
address
attitudes of certain people and we do
need to bear in mind
that most people that are involved in
these crimes
it's nothing to do with street lighting
it's assaults against women
of people people that they know and sad
that
that is how we're going to tackle that
we're never going to fix it we can only
do what we can do
thank you very much indeed for everybody
thank you councillor rock uh councillor
perry
uh perhaps you're going to conclude and
wind up this uh this debate
as i don't have any speakers after you
currently indicating councilor perry
thank you chairman i just wanted to
really pay my respect to
certainly uh chloe for sort of bringing
such an important
issue by starting this petition and i
agree with all the speakers that
that have gone before me and what
they've said and i think there's been
some this has been fantastic debate
um i certainly think osc are going to
have their
work cut out with all these um
particular motions
um and also projects to
to to look at and i think one of the
most important thing
for from a district perspective is that
it's not a one size fits all
um we're not like warwick district which
is very concentrated
we have huge sways of rural villages
and i've got a mixed board where i've
got
wellsborne village which is you know
expanding all the time
yet i have much smaller villages where
they don't want street lights on at all
so i think it's a balanced approach um
and i welcome this
um uh motion and i think there will be
some excellent work
done on taking it forward in terms of
keeping our streets
a lot safer so thanks all to everybody
and for your comments
thank you councillor parry for winding
us up so uh
extremely well so everybody's commented
i think we're all going to be in favor
of this
i think we presumably need to now take
a formal uh vote to basically say
this is an approved uh motion of notice
roll call not really necessary
um if anybody is really against it can
they indicate in the chat
other than that i will take it that it
is a unanimous support
which is where i suspect we are
i see nothing in the chat to indicate
otherwise
so that motion of notice has been
approved by the council we can now
move on to urgent business and i'll ask
the
chief executive if there is any i'm not
aware of any but i'll just seek that
clarification
mr buckland no chairman there's no
business thank you
thank you very much indeed so
councillors thank you very much indeed
and uh look forward to seeing you all
on wednesday the 19th of may as we know
we're not quite sure which the venue
may be because uh if we got face-to-face
meetings by then
uh then the council chamber will be of
insufficient capacity
but members will obviously be advised in
time uh thank you very much and good
evening
thank you thank you good night
thank you guys welcome
thanks chair yeah well done
you